madame la Présidente à la délégation au
droit des femmes mes chers collègues
c'est d'être sédataire et les
rapporteurs mais je reviendrai sur leur
cas dans un instant je voudrais vous
saluer les collègues élus et puis saluer
les je le sais les nombres collègues
élus qui sont en visio avec nous leur
souhaiter j'allais dire la bienvenue y
compris par l'image dans cette salle
Médicis du Sénat je sais que la
présidente de la FNSEA doit nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure
d'abord je suis vraiment heureux d'être
parmi vous ce matin
pour ouvrir le colloque sur les femmes
et la réalité
et je suis heureux aussi d'avoir échangé
en prolongera avec des élus des Ardennes
qui sort ici présent ma chère else
j'avais à coeur de vous accueillir mes
chers collègues dans notre assemblée
dans la vocation est d'être la caisse de
résonance
des préoccupations de terrain et en
l'occurrence de vos préoccupations de
terrain
j'avais à coeur en ce lendemain du 8
mars dédié aux femmes j'ai eu l'occasion
de m'exprimer à l'initiative de la
délégation hier genre 11 ministres des
gouvernements
oui j'avais à cœur de rendre hommage aux
femmes aux femmes élues qui parlent leur
engagement contribue de façon exemplaire
allant à l'accomplissement de l'égalité
et j'allais dire à quelque part un
regard qui est important il se trouve
que
celle qui m'a succédé est une femme
à Rambouillet après moi avoir un succédé
à un monument de l'histoire politique
française Jacqueline taupanote une des
premières femmes élues conseillée de la
République secrétaire d'État juste après
la guerre qui me permet de saluer
l'arrivée de la présidence de la
fédération nationale les syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles
[Applaudissements]
mais j'avais à cœur aussi
de remercier les 8 rapporteurs de la
délégation qui ont porté la réflexion
sur les femmes et la ruralité
Jean-Michel Arnaud
Bruno Belin n'a déjà vu pierre
maisdevielle
Marie-Pierre Monnier
Guylaine Pantel
Raymond ponce
et Marie-Claude
ce rapport me semble
à obtenir
j'allais dire une vraie réussite que
l'inscription à l'agenda politique d'un
impensé des politiques publiques les
femmes en milieu rural
la politique d'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes le plus souvent traité
comme un sujet soit Macron soit comme un
sujet national
la politique en faveur de la ruralité
est rarement conçu sous l'angle de la
parité
toute la force du rapport de la
délégation me paraît résider dans la
conjugaison de ces deux prismes parité
et ruralité
grâce à ce rapport de nombreux
responsables politiques au premier rang
desquels le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires me paraissent avoir eu la
conviction qu'il fallait articuler les
politiques publiques en faveur de
l'égalité famome et celle en faveur des
territoires ruraux afin
de les inscrire dans un processus
d'égalité territoriale
les questions d'égalité doivent toujours
être parti prenantes des politiques
d'aménagement du territoire
ceux des leur définition et lors de leur
mise en œuvre
l'aménagement du territoire ne peut se
lancer
sans la dimension égalité femme homme et
inversement les politiques d'égalité
doivent systématiquement intégrés me
semble-t-il une réflexion territoriale
la ruralité et le creuset d'inégalité
plus marquée pour les femmes je crois
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
ressort de ce rapport mais aussi de
témoignages
un déficit de mobilité individuelle
comme collective
des services publics éloignés
un manque de solutions de garde
d'enfants à proximité
des choix d'orientation scolaires plus
restreint notamment pour les jeunes
filles un manque de mixité dans
certaines branches professionnelles
un accès aux soins et à la santé plus
difficile permettez-moi moi qui dans une
vie antérieure était président de la
Fédération hospitalière de France
d'évoquer
notamment la question
des départements forts dépourvus dans le
domaine de la gynécologie
le fait aussi parfois pour des raisons
scientifiques techniques de la réalité
du nombre de maternité divisé par 3 en
40 ans
des femmes qui ont plus difficilement
accès au centre de santé et au médecin
spécialistes éloignés c'est vraiment un
sujet qui doit nous toucher
particulièrement savoir que nous avons
13 départements dépourvus de gynécologue
la réalité c'est ça et 26 départements
dans lequel pardonnez-moi je parle de
l'autre bout de la vie
il n'y a toujours pas de service de
soins palliatifs
cette réalité là parce que souvent les
femmes sont aussi des aidants et c'est
un sujet que nous aurons débat qui
parfois pourra nous diviser mais dans
les jours qui viennent d'assurance
vieillesse des aidants familiaux
c'est vraiment un sujet et que vous avez
touché au point je dirais la présidente
que ce matin étant interrogé dans une
radio nationale
j'ai évoqué en aparté le sujet et où je
me rendais personne ne mesurait cette
réalité de prise en compte et que le
rapport a vraiment touché du doigt je le
dis par la présidente de la Fédération
nationale des syndicats des exploitants
agricoles je pense qu'en plus il y a une
situation particulière pour les femmes
dans le secteur d'activité que vous
représentez madame la Présidente
j'ai pu mesurer que ces difficultés aux
soins conduisaient parfois renoncement
renoncement un suivi pourtant primordial
en matière de prévention et de faible
taux de dépistage de cancer et que ce
sujet là doit nous interpeller
réellement
oui cela nous oblige à renforcer les
moyens
accompagner les efforts et de vigilants
mais aussi dans la législation de poser
peut-être la question chaque fois nous
légiférons c'est tout l'intérêt des
délégations d'ailleurs de quelque part
ouvrir des voies nous tenir éveillées je
crois je le dis au rapporteur je crois
qu'ils ont fait œuvre utile pas
simplement mon yen le rapport mais pour
que la préoccupation qui est soulignée
dans ce rapport comme dans d'autres
rapports soit présent au moment où les
différents ou nous contrôlons où nous
évaluons
mais la ruralité c'est aussi un lieu de
créativité c'est un lieu de l'engagement
et de l'engagement hors norme de
milliers de femmes
je les mesuré dans mon département natal
où je retournais il y a quelques jours
j'allais dire presque malheureusement
mais aussi heureusement qu'on met un des
femmes qui sont je dois dire des
marqueurs dans mon département de l'Orne
qui n'est pas un département parmi les
plus favorisés mais il y a des femmes
qui jouent un rôle absolument
exceptionnel
je sais
c'était à clin d'oeil même la présidente
malgré les difficultés liées à
l'enclavement et à l'isolement il me
semble que les femmes améliorerave sont
souvent preuve d'un dynamisme d'un
esprit d'initiative avec une dimension
qui parfois peuvent nous manquer à nous
de solidarité je pense que quels sont
quelques parts décimaux de solidarité
j'espère que cette matinée vous
permettra de vous faire l'écho de ces
bonnes pratiques innovantes solutions
originales je vous souhaite une fois
encore je salue toutes celles et ceux
qui sont en visio qu'ils aient vraiment
le sentiment d'être associé à notre à
notre matinée au Sénat c'est pas
simplement une matinée étape ça doit
être aussi une référence et vous
démontrer que
l'assemblée qui est en charge par la
constitution de représenter les
territoires derrière les territoires
nous savons bien que les territoires
sont façonnés par des hommes et des
femmes par des citoyens qui au travers
notamment de la représentation
territoriale sont des acteurs de ce
progrès tous les cas je vous souhaite
encore merci au rapporteur je les vois
de territoire assez différents
et des quatre coins de l'horizon de nous
avoir livré ce rapport très bonne
matinée mais je vais rester vous écouter
madame la Présidente merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci pour votre présence votre fidélité
à nos événements et merci pour votre
accompagnement merci pour vos mots aussi
à destination des rapporteurs et de la
délégation qui ont travaillé sur femme
et ruralité en finir avec les zones
blanches madame la Présidente merci
d'être à nos côtés ce matin chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs c'est un
immense plaisir pour moi de vous
accueillir au Sénat pour cette matinée
consacrée aux femmes des territoires
ruraux par la délégation au droit des
femmes dans le cadre de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes on
n'avait pas imaginé qui aurait des
grèves de train qui empêcheraient un
certain nombre de des invités à nous
rejoindre je remercie tout
particulièrement donc le président du
Sénat d'avoir accepté
d'ouvrir notre coloc je le sais très
attentif à l'activité de notre
délégation oui Gérard Larcher n'a pas de
clone effectivement il était urgent de
retirer
ce cheval il a notamment suivi de près
nos travaux sur la situation des femmes
dans les territoires ruraux qui ont
abouti à la publication en octobre 2021
de ce rapport faméruralité en finir avec
les zones blanches de l'égalité notre
rapport femme et ruralité est le fruit
d'un travail collégial et transpartisant
il a été porté par 8 qu'aux rapporteurs
représentant chaque groupe parlementaire
du Sénat mais aussi par toute une
diversité de territoires Jean-Michel
Arnaud à la tribune sénateur des
Hautes-Alpes qui épargne minou ce matin
et qui animera notre première séquence
de la matinée il devait être accompagné
d'élus de son département qui répondu
annuler également leur venue donc on les
salue par visio interposée mais il
Monsieur le Maire de Baratier
interviendra à distance Bruno Belin
sénateur de la Vienne qui avait organisé
d'ailleurs une réunion sur cette
thématique dans son département à
laquelle Jean-Michel Arnaud et moi-même
avions participé au conseil
départemental n'a déjà-vette sénatrice
du Finistère pierre mais de vieille
sénateur de Haute-Garonne Marie-Pierre
Monnier également à la tribune sénatrice
de la Drôme parmi nous ce matin et qui
animera la seconde séquence de la
matinée les élus de son département
également
empêché on va dire donc nous écouterons
madame Perez maire de
saint-jean-de-galaure qui interviendra
en visioconférence Guylaine panten
sénatrice de la Lozère Raymonde
pontsmonge avec nous ce matin une belle
délégation sénatrice du Rhône à croire
que les grèves ne touchent pas le Rhône
en réalité vous êtes privilégié mesdames
et Marie-Claude varaiasse sénatrice de
la Dordogne Raymonde poncemonge
sénatrice du Rhône le point de départ du
travail de notre délégation sur la
situation des femmes dans les
territoires ruraux à résulter d'un
examen attentif de l'agenda rural du
gouvernement adopté à l'automne 2019
aucune des 180 mesures de cet agenda
rural ne faisait au moment de son
adoption référence à l'égalité femme
homme ni à aucune problématique
spécifique aux femmes dans les
territoires ruraux or pas moins de 11
millions de femmes vivent aujourd'hui
dans ces territoires ruraux soit une
femme sur trois c'est donc un sujet
majeur nos travaux sur le sujet ont duré
10 mois nous avons organisé une
trentaine d'heures d'audition nous avons
publié un questionnaire en ligne sur la
plateforme du Sénat de consultation des
des locaux qui nous a permis de
recueillir plus d'un millier de réponses
et témoignages enfin nos rapporteurs ont
organisé diverses rencontres dans leur
département respectifs tout ce travail a
permis de dresser un large tour
d'horizon de la situation des femmes
dans les territoires ruraux dans toute
leur diversité et à tous les âges de la
vie notre rapport couvrait plus ses
spécifiquement huit thématiques les
enjeux de mobilité articulations temps
de vie la jeunesse l'orientation
scolaire et universitaire l'emploi et
l'insertion professionnelle
l'entreprenariat au féminin le métier
d'agricultrice madame la Présidente la
santé des femmes et l'accès aux soins
auxquels monsieur le Président du Sénat
a fait référence les violences
conjugales et enfin l'engagement
politique les femmes au poste de
responsabilité politique je ne vais pas
revenir dans le détail sur l'ensemble
des constats dressés dans ce rapport ni
sur les 70 recommandations adoptées par
la délégation vous les trouverez dans
les documents disponibles d'ailleurs à
l'entrée de la salle et ça me permet de
remercier l'équipe qui nous entoure et
qui a organisé cette matinée donc
on a deux séquences ce matin dans qui
portons en chacune sur une des
thématiques du rapport la première
l'accès des familles issues de la
ruralité aux responsabilités et la
deuxième la jeunesse dans les
territoires ruraux avant d'explorer plus
précisément ces deux sujets avec
l'ensemble de nos invités j'aimerais
rappeler quelques constats issus de
notre rapport qui pour certains sont
communs à l'ensemble des thématiques et
donc déterminant pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des femmes en milieu
rural tout d'abord les enjeux de
mobilité ils irriguent l'ensemble des
difficultés auxquelles peuvent être
confrontés des femmes dans ces
territoires le manque de mobilité
l'éloignement des services et
l'insuffisance de la couverture
numérique sont les principales
difficultés rencontrées dans les
territoires ruraux et elles sont
cumulatif tout particulièrement pour les
femmes qui résident les difficultés de
mobilité signifient un accès plus
compliqué à l'emploi au service public
aux offres de soins aux modes de garde
des enfants au commerce aux associations
aux loisirs elles sont à l'origine d'un
isolement plus grand des femmes et
entrave la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes les violences
intrafamidales en rendant complexes les
déplacements en gendarmerie comme le
départ du domicile les femmes des
territoires ruraux sont particulièrement
touchés par les difficultés de mobilité
alors que la voiture représente 80% des
déplacements en zone rurale et il
constitue souvent un critère d'embauche
les femmes ont un accès moindre que les
hommes une femme sur cinq n'a pas le
permis contre un homme sur dix dans les
territoires ruraux les transports en
commun réguliers sont insuffisants et on
le comprend évidemment en milieu rural
pour en faire une solution altern je
voudrais juste raconter une anecdote à
ce moment-là j'avais ma collaboratrice
parisienne qui ne connaissait pas la
Vendée je suis sénatrice de la Vendée et
elle devait venir passer deux jours en
Vendée et avait dit aux autres
collaborateurs vous inquiétez pas je
vous rejoindrai sur le site de
l'inauguration je prendrai un uber alors
juste aux Sables-d'Olonne ça n'existe
pas ça n'existe pas donc évidemment la
mobilité c'est un autre sujet dans les
territoires ruraux que la mobilité dans
les territoires urbains donc ils sont
peu adaptés aux spécificités des
habitudes de déplacement des femmes en
août les territoires ruraux agissent
comme un amplificateur d'inégalité entre
les femmes et les hommes en matière de
conditions d'emploi les différences
constatées pour les indicateurs de taux
de chômage précarité ou temps partiel
sont en effet plus importantes dans ces
territoires que dans les territoires
urbains les territoires ruraux se
caractérisent également par une très
faible mixité de l'offre d'emploi
s'agissant de la santé et l'accès aux
soins vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président la désespertification médicale
touche particulièrement les gynécologues
13 départements sont même
il n'y a pas de
gynécologue médicale dans 13
départements 77 départements n'ont pas
suffisamment de gynécologues médicaux
pour poser un accès aux soins normal
pour toutes ces femmes ça veut dire
moins de prévention moins de taux de
dépistage des cancers féminins notamment
concernant les violences intra
familiales des territoires ruraux
concentrent la moitié des interventions
de gendarmerie pour violence
intrafamidale et la moitié des
féminicides alors que je le rappelle
seul un tiers des femmes vivent dans ces
territoires
dans ce territoire les femmes victimes
sont plus isolées moins informées moins
protégées elles sont sous représentées
dans les sollicitations des dispositifs
d'aide moins de 30% des appels au 39-19
proviennent des territoires ruraux les
acteurs locaux notamment la gendarmerie
les professionnels de santé les
associations et bien sûr les élus jouent
un rôle majeur mais manque souvent de
moyens et de coordination globalement
nous pensons donc indispensables
d'articuler les politiques publiques en
faveur de l'égalité femme homme et celle
en faveur des territoires ruraux pour en
finir avec les zones blanches de
l'égalité nous estimons que la politique
d'aménagement du territoire ne peut se
concevoir sans y intégrer la dimension
égalité femme homme et inversement les
politiques d'égalité doivent
systématiquement se fonder sur une
réflexion territoriale dans mon propos
introductif je n'ai volontairement pas
détaillé différents constats et de la
délégation concernant l'accès des femmes
aux responsabilités dans les territoires
ni se relativent aux jeunes puisque je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure ce sont mes
collègues Jean-Michel Arnaud et
Marie-Pierre Monnier qui vont s'emparer
de ces sujets et nourrir le débat avec
l'ensemble de nos invités de ce matin
alors à nouveau je vous remercie
véritablement chaleureusement pour votre
présence monsieur le Président merci
d'être à nos côtés et je nous souhaite à
tous collectivement une belle réunion je
sais d'immédiatement la parole à
Monsieur le corps rapporteur Jean-Michel
Arnaud et je salue les co-rapporteurs
dans la salle qui sont avec nous
également et qui avait fait un travail à
la fois au Sénat pendant ces longs mois
mais également dans leur territoire
puisque j'évoquais tout à l'heure cher
Bruno se déplacement dans la Vienne par
exemple merci à tous et à toutes et à
remerciement particulier à notre
président merci
merci
chers collègue je tiens évidemment à
saluer à la fois le travail et pilotage
notre délégation par Annick billon
toutes ces années avec
je pense un crantage qui s'est amélioré
fortement sur les questions
de femmes et égalité femme homme dans
notre assemblée et puis ça lui
évidemment le président de Larcher qui a
dit tout à l'heure Annick que tu n'étais
pas le clone de Gérard Larcher mais j'ai
l'impression que gérarchique parce qu'on
le voit présent
à tous les rendez-vous importants de
notre assemblée et encore hier
après-midi
à la séance pour les retraites hier midi
lors du déjeuner avec le 11 ministres
cette nuit enfin voilà vous êtes
effectivement
un phare important pour l'engagement
politique dans notre assemblée et vous
êtes présent auprès de toutes les causes
défendues par nos collègues donc la
première séquence aujourd'hui de notre
matinée est consacrée l'engagement des
femmes des territoires ruraux en
politique mais aussi au sein de
structures associatives ou syndicales ce
sont au niveau local au niveau national
nous intéresserons dans cette première
séquence aux fringues qui ont rave
encore cet engagement mais également en
mesure qui pourrait te permettre de
l'encourager je suis très heureux
d'accueillir Christian Lambert pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
après à côté de Nicole cotta qui a été
une grande figure du syndicalisme
français elle a incarné vous avez
incarné madame depuis une quarantaine
d'années
un engagement sans faille auprès des
agriculteurs de France et je suis
hansela et je sais aussi votre présence
un peu comme je Gérard Larcher notre
président partout sur les territoires de
France au contact de la réalité de
terrain pour pouvoir défendre au mieux
les causes agricoles et notamment les
femmes dans leur engagement politique
dans quelle préparation du rapport
auquel il a été fait allusion tout à
l'heure chacun des co-rapporteurs avait
organisé des rencontres dans son
département afin d'échanger avec des
acteurs de terrain et de recueillir
également des témoignages au plus près
de nos territoires j'avais pour ma part
il y a maintenant deux ans organisé une
rencontre dans mon département
réunissant plusieurs centaines de
collègues femmes
nous avions accepté quelques hommes à
cette réunion
qui avait été l'occasion d'échanger avec
de nombreuses femmes élues sur leurs
difficultés mais aussi sur leur réussite
et leur fierté sur les leviers qu'elles
identifiés pour faire progresser la
parité et l'accès des femmes aux
responsabilités ces témoignages comme
cela a été dit par Annick billon
confortait par un questionnaire auquel
mille personnes ont répondu que nous
ayons adressé donc à l'ensemble des
femmes et des élus rurales ainsi que par
les tables ronds que nous avons
organisés ont été la source
d'information précieuses pour notre
rapport les principales difficultés
rencontrées mentionnées révélés par les
élus femmes portent essentiellement sur
la conciliation des vies politiques
professionnelles et familiales j'avais
au moment du café d'accueil de ce matin
un échange avec une élue
de l'Est de la France qui m'indiquait
ses difficultés y compris pour une
commune de 200 habitants de concilier
son engagement professionnel son
engagement et son animation dans la
commune et l'intercommunalité qui
constitue un élément d'engagement très
important pour les communes rurales
nous avons également pointé un certain
nombre d'insuffisances liées aux statut
de l'élu et sur la persistance disons-le
du sexisme notamment dans l'attribution
délégation au sein des conseils
municipaux tant en nombre que par la
nature de ces délégations ces
difficultés expliquent que si les femmes
représentent aujourd'hui 42% des élus
locaux et l'on ne peut que ça féliciter
elle ne représente encore que 20% des
mers 11% seulement des présidents de
conseils communautaires agglomération
comme des communes comme des
agglomération et métropoles 20% des
présidents de conseil départementaux et
un tiers des présidents de région
en outre le nombre de femmes restent
encore limitées au sein des conseils
municipaux des communes de moins de 1000
habitants qui représentent je dois le
rappeler trois quarts des communes
françaises et pour lesquelles le scrutin
de liste paritaire ne s'applique pas
dans pardon n'est ainsi que de 38%
contre 49% dans les communes de 1000
habitants ou plus qui bénéficient du
scrutin de disparitaire ces différents
constats nous amenés à formuler cette
recommandations afin de d'augmenter de
favoriser la mixité dans la vie
politique locale
tout d'abord nous avons souhaité et
c'était un point
d'unanimité après une longue discussion
au sein de notre délégation de faire
sauter le verrou des 1000 habitants et
détendre à toutes les communes les
obligations de parité aux élections
municipales nous n'allons pas ouvrir le
débat je sais des difficultés que cela
repose mais j'ai vu également que grâce
à ce rapport ou dans le cadre se
rapporte ou dans le contexte ce rapport
les lignes ont un peu bougé y compris au
sein de l'association des mers ruraux de
France qui depuis a revendiqué porte
l'idée d'une parité avec des adaptations
sur le nombre de conseils municipaux
mais je crois que un verrou est passé et
j'espère que cette question pourra
prospérer dans nos assemblées
parlementaires pourquoi pas au Sénat
mais cette affaire est une autre
question monsieur le Président en
parallèle nous souhaitons également
appliquer à toutes les communes le
système de fléchage pour les élections
intercommunales avec obligation de
disparitaire nous avons également
formulé des recommandations en matière
de statut notamment afin de faciliter
les gardes pendant les réunions même
s'il est prévu formellement des
dispositifs aujourd'hui dans le cadre
légal mais qui sont difficilement
applicables et difficiles de demander à
une commune rurale d'indemniser avec les
moyens budgétaires qui sont les leurs
les gardes de concert municipales
d'adjointe ou de maire qui font face à
leur responsabilité municipale nous
souhaitons également la création
l'émergence d'un référent égalité au
sein de toutes les communes et
intercommunalités qui pourraient
d'ailleurs servir tant aux élus
municipaux aux responsabilités induite
par ces fonctions municipales mais aussi
permettre d'avoir un dialogue avec les
femmes des villages des communes rurales
de France sur ces sujets et ouvrir le
débat sociologiquement s'agissant de
l'engagement des femmes au sein des
instances professionnelles et syndicales
madame la Présidente nous avions par
exemple recommandé dans notre rapport
d'instaurer des quotas au sein des
instances de gouvernance agricoles sujet
important sur lequel je ne doute pas
vous réagirez et de réfléchir à
l'application de quotas dans les
conseils d'administrations notamment des
coopératives et interprofessions
agricoles même si je sais que la
question de la coopérative dans le monde
agricole pose question avec un
désengagement des adhérents des
coopératives dans la gouvernance du
quotidien j'ai vu un certain nombre de
rapport à cet effet mais je crois qu'il
est important d'ouvrir de nouvelles
voies pour l'égalité et la parité dans
ces organismes nous sommes aussi
également très favorable au soutien et
au développement de Réseau des femmes
dans tous les secteurs professionnels
syndicaux associatifs ou politiques nous
avons notamment l'occasion de ce rapport
auditionner un certain nombre de jeunes
femmes étudiantes qui à partir de zones
rurales développent des réseaux pour
faciliter la confiance des filles
rurales de tutorat monitorat presque en
faveur des jeunes filles des zones
rurales pour leur donner envie et
surtout confiance à entrer dans des
filières professionnelles de haute
qualité et de haut niveau nous sommes
également très favorables au soutien au
développement
de réseau d'entraide plus elles sont
puissantes c'est réseau d'entraide plus
elles seront effectivement un vecteur
d'influence dans tous les domaines et
nous pouvons évidemment qu'encourager
cela dans une optique ont également de
partage d'expérience et d'échanges
autour de ces différents constats et
recommandations je suis comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure très heureux
avec les collègues de la délégation
d'accueillir madame Lambert présidente
encore pour quelques semaines et ce
depuis 2017 du premier syndicat
d'exploitant agricole de France la FNSEA
et après avoir gravi tous et les
échelons du syndicalisme agricole et
puis avoir été également très présent
sur son exploitation menée de manière
familiale avec également une capacité
d'adaptation de l'exploitation agricole
familiale aux exigences et aux
évolutions techniques nécessité par
l'ouverture du marché et la nécessité
d'être également en performance
économique donc vous êtes madame la
Présidente évidemment ici dans votre
maison puisque vous représentez les
agriculteurs de France donc les
territoires de France à travers cette
profession et nous sommes évidemment
très attentifs aux propos que nous
tiendrez et probablement en forme aussi
de retour d'expérience et peut-être un
fil directeur d'héritage culturel que
vous pourrez peut-être laisser après
avoir mené avec brio la FNSEA en termes
de présidence ces dernières années nous
vous laissons bien évidemment la parole
et en espérant que vous éclairerez nos
débats de votre expérience et surtout de
votre vision de la ruralité
particulièrement façonnée par votre
expérience syndicale vous voulez sur la
parole madame
merci beaucoup combien de temps me
donnez-vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Larcher je suis ravi de vous retrouver
la dernière fois que nous sommes vus
c'était devant l'assemblée des
vétérinaires professions qui vous est
cher et qui est essentiel à notre
secteur aussi
chers
Monsieur Arnaud mesdames et
messieurs il y en a pas beaucoup mais
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrice sénateur merci pour
l'invitation j'avais eu l'occasion de
travailler d'être auditionné je me
souviens Manic billon m'avait invité
nous avions déjà travaillé ensemble et
puis j'avais lu avec beaucoup d'intérêts
et la Commission des agriculteurs de la
FNSEA lui avec intérêt le rapport lors
de sa sortie avec un certain nombre de
constats que nous partageons mais aussi
de souhaits d'amélioration que nous
partageons
et avons essayé de résoudre alors
peut-être d'abord quelques mots de
présentation
donc je suis née dans le Cantal en 1961
à l'époque le mot agricultrice n'était
pas dans le Petit Larousse c'est l'année
où le mot agricultrice est rentré dans
le Petit Larousse 1961 de parents
agriculteurs tous les deux tous les deux
militants à la JAC tous les deux
travailleurs enthousiastes et optimistes
et persuadé qu'en travaillant en plus
ils améliorer leur sort c'était les
années où l'agriculture était en plein
développement plein essor parce que
Michel de Battice avait appelé la
révolution silencieuse beaucoup de
changements dans les exploitations
agricoles avec des jeunes qui arrivaient
plein d'espoir et d'envie de changement
pour leur profession et on peut dire au
regard de l'histoire qu'ils ont plutôt
bien réussi j'ai choisi d'être
agricultrice à l'âge de 8 ans en
travaillant avec ma maman dans
l'exploitation je la suivais partout
parce que je préférais être au boulot
dans l'exploitation avec elle qu'à faire
mes devoirs même si j'ai bien fait mes
devoirs puisque j'ai eu mon brevet mon
bac mon BTS etc
et comme j'étais plutôt bon élève on m'a
plus mes professeurs et mes maîtres de
stage ont souvent découragé dissuadé
d'être agricultrice en disant tu réussis
bien à l'école tu devrais faire un autre
métier et alors c'est pas parce que je
suis Auvergnate et à fort caractère que
je me suis obstiné à devenir mais c'est
vraiment par patience donc j'ai choisi
d'aller dans une école d'agriculture et
j'ai fait un bac agricole un brevet
d'acquisition supérieur et à 19 ans
pile le jour de mes 19 ans j'ai eu mon
BTS et je me suis installé 5 jours après
sur une exploitation voisine de celle de
mes parents
sans difficulté pour trouver du foncier
mais un accueil plutôt frileux chez le
banquier qui m'a dit mademoiselle une
jeune fille qui s'installe à 19 ans
célibataire n'est pas un élément stable
et sécurisant je cite voilà et donc
heureusement il y avait mes parents à
côté la caution de mes parents pour
arriver à
emprunter réaliser les empreintes dont
j'avais besoin pour installer une
exploitation on va chez laitière et port
je vais pendant mes études beaucoup
côtoyées de jeunes d'un petit peu tous
les régions de France parce que étant
d'une famille modeste nous dédions
jamais partir en vacances en famille
mais par contre le BTS m'a permis de
raconter des jeunes filles agriculteurs
ou pas de plus de 40 départements ce qui
a représenté une formidable ouverture
d'esprit et aussi une approche très
positive de l'agriculture vécu comme je
le vivais dans le Cantal mais découvrant
d'autres façons de l'être dans le dans
toute la France et me donnant envie
justement de cette curiosité à
préserver pendant mes études nous avons
accueilli un jeune vice-président du
cnga un jeune agriculteur de Haute-Loire
je fais mes études en Haute-Loire
puisque je suis né dans le Cantal à
Saint-Flour et j'étais agricultrice sur
le canton la commune de Massiac
qui est celle d'Alain marlex mère et
c'est aujourd'hui Olivier Malek son fils
qui lui en Eure-et-Loir donc je me
trompe souvent de prénom encore parce
que j'ai beaucoup côtoyé Monsieur Alain
marlex et installé dans le Cantal et
j'ai un peu perdu mon fil nous j'avais
pour projet donc de développer cette
exploitation et je l'ai développé
travaillant seul célibataire et puis
j'ai eu tout de suite des engagements
professionnels parce que ayant et
entendu ce jeune agriculteur emploi
pendant mes études du CNGE m'étais dit
voilà quelqu'un qui agriculteur au fin
fond de la Haute-Loire qui est un
département très rural et dans un une
commune très isolée il était un
millimètre d'altitude il avait une
connaissance parfaite du monde et des
enjeux agricoles et j'ai été
impressionnée par sa capacité d'analyse
on éloquence et je me suis dit waouh le
CNJA c'est vraiment une belle
organisation et donc dès que je suis
arrivé dans le Cantal j'ai été approché
pour rentrer dans l'équipe cantonale des
jeunes agriculteurs et j'ai commencé
ainsi à l'échelle locale la plus locale
la commune canton et j'ai apprécié
justement d'avoir cette liberté
d'initiative
et de pouvoir faire organiser un certain
nombre de réunions qui réunissait de
plus en plus d'agriculteurs preuves
qu'il y avait un vrai besoin d'organiser
des lieux de rencontre et d'échanges
entre les agriculteurs au début nous
étions 10 puis 15 puis 20 puis à
l'assemblée générale nous étions 55
l'effet boule de neige parle l'intérêt
des thèmes que nous choisissions et qui
correspondait aux besoins qui étaient
les leurs de rencontrer qui un
vétérinaire député européen qui était de
Brioude d'ailleurs qui nous avait
beaucoup éclairé sur ce qui se passait
au niveau européen cette liberté
d'organisation que l'on a quand on est
dans ce type de syndicat où on peut
faire finalement plein de choses
ainsi ont commencé mais mes
responsabilités
vice-président du département du Cantal
en côtoyant des gens brillants Michel
tessaou et un certain nombre d'autres
dirigeants et c'est très souvent des
personnes des contacts des personnes
charismatiques qui donnent envie de
s'engager davantage
j'ai poursuivi en étant vice-président
départemental puis présente régional en
Auvergne puis j'ai tout arrêté parce que
j'avais rencontré Thierry mon mari qui
lui était du Maine-et-Loire et nous
avons décidé de changer de région mais
voilà arrivée en Pays de la Loire en
1989 où j'ai repris toujours au niveau
du canton des responsabilités attirées
par des gens qui m'avaient côtoyé à
Paris lorsque j'étais en Cantal et de
fil en aiguille et pourquoi ai-je ce
jeune de la responsabilité c'est un
petit peu la question qu'on peut se
poser ce besoin de de s'engager ailleurs
de ne pas rester seulement en
responsabilité sur son exploitation avec
sa famille l'exploitation qui déjà
occupe beaucoup mais ce besoin de faire
avec les autres et pour les autres je
crois que c'est quelque chose qu'on
hérite de ses parents d'une culture
d'une éducation que j'ai eu la chance
aussi de développer dans mon
établissement d'enseignement
l'Institut Saint-Dominique au
Puy-en-Velay Haute-Loire donc le
leitmotiv était ouverture d'esprit et
esprit de synthèse ouverture d'esprit
c'est à dire qu'on nous engageait
vraiment à aller voir ailleurs mais
vraiment ailleurs quand je vais conduire
rencontré le président du tribunal dans
le juge pour enfants le juge pour
enfants de la ville du Puy et on avait
fait donc un rapport sur ce sujet
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'intéressait à plein
de thématiques extérieures et finalement
cette culture générale a été très
bénéfique ensuite
et esprit de synthèse c'est-à-dire voir
tout ça et puis garder le meilleur pour
soi et se construire et construire ses
convictions
ça m'a beaucoup aidé par la suite aussi
y compris en termes de curiosité mais de
tolérance aussi dans les rencontres et
les personnes côtoyées et puis parce que
le jeune de la responsabilité hérité de
mes parents
déléguer de classe capitaine de l'équipe
de handball ça m'a suivi un petit peu
partout donc très vite on va confier des
responsabilités et l'originalité du
syndicalisme agricole qui n'existe pas
partout c'est qu'il y a une vie
présidente féminine statutaire
des sa création à la fois le CNJA et la
FNSEA ont créé un poste statutaire
qu'une pour qu'une femme soit
vice-présidente pourquoi parce que dans
le secteur agricole dans notre domaine
depuis toujours révéler davantage encore
par la guerre ou les hommes étaient au
front et les femmes ont tenu les
exploitations vous avez certainement vu
le documentaire nous paysan qui a bien
mis en avant le rôle des femmes en
agriculture pour tenir les exploitations
les mers les filles pendant que les
pères et les frères étaient au combat
elles ont tenu la nation comme avaient
dit le général de Gaulle et elles ont
joué un rôle très important dans cette
la connaissance elle est venue alors
d'abord alors une vis prudence féminine
depuis une section féminine spécifique
pour accompagner les femmes qui avaient
des besoins particuliers n'étant pas
aussi rompus que les hommes aux tâches
certaines femmes venant à l'agriculture
par le mariage sans avoir une formation
ni la possibilité d'avoir une compétence
propre donc la nécessité de faire de la
formation continue d'insérer
d'accompagner et finalement cette
vice-présence féminine elle a permis
aussi de faire que certaines femmes qui
n'auraient pas forcément accepté a
priori ont été un peu poussés à prendre
cette responsabilité en disant voilà il
nous faut une femme il nous faut une
femme alors c'est un petit peu comme les
conseils municipaux quand on cherche la
parité il y a certaines personnes qui se
jettent certaines femmes qui se mettent
pas en avant qui se jettent pas dans les
responsabilités qu'il faut un peu
pousser pour que finalement les
acceptent et on se rend compte quelques
années après que finalement les exels
dans leur responsabilité et puis l'autre
très très bien leur dossiers elles
apportent beaucoup aussi dans l'équipe
du groupe quel qu'il soit donc arrivé
dans le Maine-et-Loire réinstallation
dans le Maine-et-Loire arrivé d'un
enfant puis deux enfants donc refus
d'avoir une responsabilité nationale
parce que les enfants étaient très
petits et puis en 1992 donc Thibault
avait un an et Guillaume avait trois ans
j'ai accédé au niveau du Conseil
administration des jeunes agriculteurs
et il y a eu là deux choses
déterminantes d'abord le dialogue avec
mon mari qui a toujours accompagné mais
mes responsabilités alors j'ouvre une
parenthèse mais la semaine dernière au
salon de l'agriculture dans un dîner
prestigieux une dame prestigieuse
responsable d'une grande maison de vin
me dit mais madame vous responsabilités
votre mari les a acceptées ou les voulu
avez imposé j'étais très surprise de
cette question parce que vous imaginez
bien qu'un engagement qui prend autant
de temps et dans la durée si c'est
imposé ça ne marcherait pas donc il faut
vraiment le partage au sein du couple et
c'est sur quelque chose sur quoi
j'insiste beaucoup beaucoup
37 ans de mariage donc ça va c'est ça
veut dire qu'il est pas trop contraint
et c'est aussi partager la même
conviction les mêmes convictions
partager beaucoup sur le pourquoi de
l'engagement parce que l'absence est
quand même à gérer l'absence et tout ce
qui va avec à la fois en termes
personnel familial vis-à-vis des enfants
et dans l'organisation de l'intendance
de la maison
et donc Thierry quand j'ai été
sollicitée pour être président du CNJA
m'a dit que tu sois numéro 1 numéro 2 tu
vas bosser autant donc vas-y et on
s'organise et j'avoue que ça ça allège
énormément le cœur par rapport à la
décision et au fait de dire oui qui est
toujours un moment difficile de dire oui
chacune d'entre vous s'en rappelle
certainement le jour on dit oui le soir
on se couche en disant voilà qu'est-ce
que j'ai accepté est-ce que je vais y
arriver est-ce que ça va pas être trop
compliqué ou est-ce que je vais tenir
toutes les clés est-ce que je vais
réussir partout et puis le deuxième
élément c'est mon Président des Jeunes
Agriculteurs du Maine-et-Loire qui
s'appelle Jean-Marc Lézé et qui m'a dit
nous on a envie que tu sois responsable
pour le département de Maine-et-Loire
vas-y et au lieu d'avoir un agent de
remplacement donc service de
remplacement qui vient faire le travail
à la place de l'élu homme c'est une
jeune c'est une nounou qu'il m'a proposé
de de chercher pour pouvoir garder mes
enfants petits un an et trois ans et
pouvoir ainsi rester à la maison à
chaque fois que nous étions nous absent
tous les deux parce que Thierry
travaillant sur l'exploitation il y
avait des moments où les enfants étaient
seuls et
donc ces deux personnes ont joué un rôle
très important
et donc nous avons recruté une jeune
femme qui s'appelle Laure et qui a élevé
nos Guillaume Thibault les premiers puis
après le CNJA pauline est arrivé donc
10 ans 8 ans un an et donc l'or est
resté 23 ans à la maison la même nounou
non-stop elle fait partie de la famille
et les marènes de Pauline et c'est
quelqu'un qui a été déterminant dans la
sérénité qui a été la mienne pour
conduire mes responsabilités parce que
je savais qu'à la maison les choses
étaient bien tenues elle a les mêmes
valeurs que nous elle partage les mêmes
valeurs par rapport à le respect la
rigueur la famille le travail elle a
bien accompagné les enfants dans leurs
études ils ont tous les trois eu un bac
avec pension très bien donc elle est
très fière aussi d'avoir bien accompagné
les enfants dans de cette façon là et
c'est une fierté partagée puisque elle
est très proche de nous encore
aujourd'hui et ce qui veut dire que et
les femmes sont plus prêtes à témoigner
de ces éléments facilitateurs parce que
ça rejoint un certain nombre d'éléments
évoqués par Monsieur le Président et
paradige billon aussi la faiblesse de
garde en milieu rurale la difficulté
d'avoir des halte-garderie des nounous
alors maintenant il y a davantage
d'infrastructures mais l'époque il n'y
avait aujourd'hui il y a une maison
maternelle dans notre commune à l'époque
il y en avait pas et donc il fallait
organiser tout cela donc la
responsabilité c'est c'est d'abord
accepter de dire oui je veux le faire ce
qui est pas évident on hésite quand même
à dire j'ai envie de le faire vous avez
si tu es Nicole nota Nicole nota quand
elle a été pressenti pour être président
de la CFDT tous les jours d'outils voilà
une femme ambitieuse qui arrive à la
tête de la CFDT parce qu'une femme qui
veut y aller l'ambitieuse un homme et on
lui demande d'y aller quoi c'est c'est
quand même encore un peu ancré dans les
approches et puis de fil en aiguille
présidente du CNJA 2 ans après donc
pendant 4 ans ou pas de course en
portant des sujets d'importance la
saison des jeunes agriculteurs le
renouvellement l'importance d'avoir des
jeunes qui arrivent dans les communes
pour la vitalité des communes rurales
qu'on a vraiment mis en avant avec notre
formule fétiche nous avons plus besoin
de voisins que d'hectares qui nous
venait de responsables de l'Aveyron en
disant bien que renouveler les
exploitations agricoles étaient la clé
de la vitalité des villages et des
communes rurales
et puis après Harry parce qu'à 35 ans
chez les jeunes agriculteurs il y a une
date de péremption on n'est plus jeune
agriculteur donc j'ai tout arrêté puis
pauline est né parce que nous avions un
objectif d'avoir trois enfants et nous
avons trois enfants de garçons et une
fille et j'ai repris très vite des
responsabilités pour l'anecdote j'ai été
élu au Conseil administration de la du
Maine-et-Loire alors j'étais sur mon lit
de maternité Pauline venait de naître et
c'est ce jour-là qui m'ont élu au
conseil d'administration de lave-vaissa
du Maine-et-Loire c'est vrai que j'aime
l'action collective et j'aime
l'engagement pour l'action c'est à dire
conduire des projets animer des équipes
entraîner des équipes j'ai mis en place
une école de formation pour les jeunes
responsables dans le Maine-et-Loire
quand je suis arrivé dans le
Maine-et-Loire parce que pour exercer
des responsabilités et vous le savez
toutes il faut quand même une maîtrise
des dossiers une maîtrise de la prise de
parole une maîtrise de pilotage de
réunion et certaines ont instinctivement
mais pas tous et c'est toujours mieux
d'avoir justement plus de capacités
d'assurance
pour
pour bien travailler mais aussi
peut-être je vais pas dire asseoir son
autorité mais quand même montrer qu'on
est en capacité de faire et faire que
les réunions sont bien conduites
rigoureuses et que ces productif quoi je
dis souvent que quand on laisse deux
enfants ou trois enfants à la maison on
peut pas partir pour buller à
l'extérieur il faut que ce qu'on fasse à
l'extérieur soit efficace utile apporte
vraiment quelque chose à la cause pour
laquelle on s'engage
alors j'ai bien j'ai conduit pas mal de
dossiers avec plaisir j'ai pris plaisir
dans mes responsabilités j'ose le dire
j'ai jamais présenté mes responsabilités
sous un angle sacrificiel ou complexité
parce que j'ai apprécié le contact j'ai
apprécié dans les déséquilles de voir
des gens grandir dans la responsabilité
et comme je me suis engagée à l'âge de
19 ans et demi et que j'en ai
aujourd'hui 61 ans et demi j'ai vu aussi
grandir des responsables qui ont
commencé timides assez peu engagés mais
qui aujourd'hui sont brillants Excel et
sont aussi en pleine exercice de
responsabilité et ça c'est gratifiant
c'est à dire que la responsabilité c'est
aussi s'entourer de
d'agriculteurs d'agricultrices de
collaborateur aussi qui nous aide
beaucoup j'étais huit jours au salon de
l'agriculture j'ai passé tout mon
dimanche au bureau de la FNSEA rattrapé
mon retard de mail et ma gestion de
courrier de dossiers de préparation de
réunions et hier soir mon directeur me
disait que je lui avais envoyé 90 mails
dimanche dans la journée le dimanche il
les a compté bon je n'avais pas compté
j'ai quand même vérifié qu'il exagère
pas un peu
mais je sais que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
éclusé tous les mails de la semaine pour
éviter d'avoir du retard ou de passer à
côté
on sollicite aussi beaucoup nos
collaborateurs coloratrices en ont
responsabilités donc ainsi il va la
vivre alors comment suis-je arrivé à la
présidence de la FNSEA j'étais première
vice-présidente de Xavier Belin c'est
Jean-Michel entrer comme vice-présidente
et pas vice-présidente féminine
statutaire c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
une femme qui était Président des
agriculteurs qui elle y était
statutairement mais moi j'ai été élu
parce que j'étais président
départemental du Maine-et-Loire pendant
10 ans et donc je suis rentré parce que
j'avais une responsabilité territoriale
en département j'ai piloté pas mal de
dossiers Xavier Belin m'a fait confiance
pour être première vice-présidente alors
c'est vrai que récemment on m'a présenté
comme le maillot jaune la maillot jaune
des premières parce que première fois
présente des jeunes agriculteurs
première femme première vice-présente
première femme brillant de l'effet de
première femme président du copal
syndicat européen
parce que c'est un cheminement et j'ai
hésité beaucoup à être présents européen
mais vu l'importance des sujets
européens pour l'agriculture beaucoup
d'horizons pour la nourriture sont
européens la politique agricole commune
les textes environnementaux les textes
sur les normes sanitaires se passent
tous à Bruxelles d'où l'importance d'y
avoir un pied et surtout une oreille et
une tête pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses donc finalement c'est plus le
sentiment qu'il fallait faire les choses
un sentiment de devoir qu'un sentiment
de pouvoir qui m'a amené à prendre ses
responsabilités là alors avec beaucoup
d'insomnies parce que je suis pas
quelqu'un qui est hyper sûre je suis
perfectionniste et j'aime faire les
choses bien mais je me pose toujours la
question est-ce que j'en fais assez
est-ce que je fais comme il faut
d'où parfois un certain une certaine
pression au stress sur mes
collaborateurs pour leur demander de
m'aider à faire plus
vous m'interrogez sur les freins quels
sont les freins alors le premier frein
très souvent il est dans la tête des
agricultrices elles-mêmes qui hésitent à
y aller mon ami Jean-Marc Lézé présente
Jr me disait souvent tu sais quand on
demande à une femme de venir en
responsabilité elle dit souvent pourquoi
moi et quand on dit non un homme il dit
pourquoi pas moi donc j'aime bien sa
formule et je la répète et bon c'est
pareil chez vous bon alors il est pas le
seul à le penser et c'est pour ça que la
prison des agricules chez nous dit
souvent mais oser osez vous engager
osez dire oui je dois pouvoir le faire
oui j'ai envie de le faire donc oser
s'engager il est aussi par rapport à un
manque de formation certaines femmes qui
sont venus à l'agriculture sans être
formé il y en a de moins en moins parce
que maintenant les femmes choisissent
vraiment ce métier se forment et
lorsqu'elles n'auront pas la formation
initiale il existe des formations
continues qui permettent justement
d'avoir les compétences et pour discuter
d'égal égal en réunion ou même en
négociation c'est mieux d'avoir une
formation et des bases de connaissances
agricole entre France et c'est parfois
la famille c'est à dire le conjoint qui
vit mal la prise de responsabilité par
rapport à l'organisation que ça suppose
dans la famille par rapport à la garde
des enfants il y a pas toujours les
halte-garderie ça a été vous l'avez très
bien dit on n'a pas les nounous les
halte-garderie les mamans etc etc qui
permettent de solutionner le sujet
enfant culturellement dans notre culture
gidéo-chrétienne cette responsabilité
incomplit aux femmes dans le foyer et
parce que dans les exploitations il y a
beaucoup de travail c'est difficile
parfois pour les hommes de concilier
s'occuper des enfants en aisant nous et
même si ça change beaucoup dans ma
commune nous avons trois agriculteurs
dont l'épouse travaillait à l'extérieur
et ce sont eux qui ont pris totalement
en charge préparez les enfants le matin
on les enfants à l'école aller chercher
à la cantine parce qu'elles ont des
parce que les enfants ont des comment ça
s'appelle pas des impasses alimentaires
comme on dit des
voilà pas de gluten pas de CI pas de ça
donc des spécificités voilà des
intolérances merci j'ai pas trouvé le
bon voilà et qui vont les chercher à
16h30 et qui font le goûter et qui
repartent après soigner leurs animaux ce
temps choisi un agriculture beaucoup ne
mesure pas suffisamment la chance que ça
peut représenter par rapport à d'autres
professions par rapport aussi au métier
de sénateur enfin la fonction de
sénateur sénatrice qui vous appelle à
Paris quand c'est à Paris vous pouvez
pas être à 16h30 pour récupérer les
enfants à la sortie de l'école donc le
travail dans l'exploitation les horaires
de réunion alors les horaires à 18h ou
les horaires à 20h30 c'est compliqué
donc ça aussi choisir les horaires par
rapport à des horaires de femmes maman
c'est aussi quelque chose qui n'était
pas fait chez nous et on a essayé de
pallier à toutes ces à tous ces freins
avec notre commission des agricultrices
qui a quand même bien travaillé sur ces
sujets les règles ont changé au niveau
des chambres d'agriculture nous devons
avoir 30% de femmes sur les listes des
chambres d'agriculture
et c'est pas 14 femmes puissent en fin
de liste c'est deux femmes de deux
hommes une femme deux hommes une femme
deux hommes une femme tout au long de la
liste ce qui a permis à plus de femmes
d'arriver en responsabilité dans les
champs de l'agriculture et là aussi ils
sont allés chercher parfois des
agricultrices qui ne voulaient pas mais
non je peux pas tout ça et qui
finalement se révèle très bien dans leur
responsabilités pilotant des dossiers
qui de formation qui de projets
alimentaires terriers territoriaux etc
etc ce que les femmes quand elles sont
en situation de faire elles se donnent
les moyens de faire et très
majoritairement elle réussissent et du
coup elles engage un second mandat voir
un troisième mandat il y a aujourd'hui
plus de femmes prises de champs
d'agriculture qui vient n'a jamais eu
puisque je crois qu'il y en a cinq
aujourd'hui alors dans notre
organisation nous n'avons pas de quota
la présidente de la commission nationale
des agricultrices l'avaient évoqué nous
n'avons pas voulu basculer vers un
système de quota en agriculture il y a
33% d'actifs qui sont des femmes 25% son
chef d'exploitation donc responsable de
l'exploitation agricole 25%. donc nous
on ne veut surtout pas la parité 55 ans
parce que de toute façon on n'aurait pas
les femmes pour prendre ses postes là
par contre à 30% c'est quelque chose que
nous poussons vraiment alors nous
n'avons pas établi encore à la FNSEA
peut-être faudra-t-il le faire un jour
mais on a des scores qui se sont
améliorés on a aujourd'hui trois femmes
sur un bureau de 26 c'est plus qu'il n'y
a jamais eu nous avons 13 femmes au
niveau du conseil d'administration de 69
personnes donc c'est aussi un chiffre le
plus élevé que nous n'ayons jamais eu
nous avons 12 femmes présidentes
départementales une seule présidente de
région celle de l'Orne donc chez
Monsieur Larcher et cinq femmes
présidentes d'associations spécialisées
c'est à dire que c'est une femme qui
préside notre fédération des chevaux des
ovins de des fruits
du riz donc voilà c'est dans ces
productions là
le basculement qu'auteur dans nos têtes
nous n'y sommes pas prêts il y a encore
cette crainte je sais que c'est un sujet
qui est très très souvent débattu dans
plein d'orientation de conseils
d'administration j'espère que nous n'y
arriverons pas nous avons aujourd'hui
plus de femmes qui s'installe on a tente
2% de l'installation de jeunes
agriculteurs qui sont le fait de femmes
et nous avons dans les écoles
d'agriculture de plus en plus de jeunes
filles on est aujourd'hui à 52% de
filles 48% de garçons et Pauline notre
fille qui a fait un diplôme d'ingénieur
agronome à Rennes
[Musique]
il y avait 68 % de filles dans sa classe
68% de filles dans sa classe donc ça
s'améliore toutes les filles ont trouvé
du boulot certaines sont agricultrices
d'autres sont conseillères mais tout ont
trouvé du travail dans les trois mois
qui ont suivi c'est assez impressionnant
de voir cette réussite là et cet intérêt
pour les pour les agricultrices pour le
métier d'agriculture donc nous avons
besoin de bras sauf si on appelle que
nous lançons pour accueillir des jeunes
filles accueillir des jeunes femmes il y
a des femmes de plus en plus de femmes
vétérinaires il y avait au début des
crânes de la part des agriculteurs il y
en a plus
tous les métiers même des métiers qui
étaient exclusivement masculins
auparavant sont aujourd'hui choisis par
des jeunes filles et c'est très bien
donc voilà on va continuer dans la
mesure du possible à lever tous les
freins je vous en prie à lever tous les
freins pour coordonner davantage parce
que dans l'équilibre du groupe c'est
vrai qu'avoir des femmes dans nos
groupes qui sont quand même
majoritairement masculins c'est un
apport important voilà j'arrête et je
répondrai des questions s'il y en a
merci beaucoup merci on peut applaudir
madame Lambert
merci madame la Présidente de vos
témoignages j'en profite pour saluer
l'arrivée d'un certain nombre de
collègues qui ont réussi à dépasser des
Ardennes qui ont réussi à dépasser les
problèmes de d'embouteillage sur la
périphérie de Paris et je salue
également Valérie de l'État
vice-président du Sénat qui a marqué
l'actualité de ces dernières semaines
par son engagement permanent au service
de la cause des femmes et singulièrement
pour l'aide d'urgence pour les victimes
de violence conjugales textes que
Valérie a réussi à faire aboutir
et puis je crois en citant Valérie et la
fierté de ton mandat
je vous propose d'enchaîner par le
témoignage d'une deuxième invité cette
fois-ci en visio Christine maximum
maire de Baratier dans les Hautes-Alpes
une commune touristique rurale de 600
habitants
vice-président de la Comté de commune de
Serre-Ponçon en brun qui est par
ailleurs
ma suppléante ça tout est dit et qui
surtout à l'ambition à travers sa
présentation de vous indiquer également
le cheminement à l'image de ce qui a été
dit par la présidente Lambert d'un
engagement et je laisse donc à Christine
maximale le soin de nous présenter son
parcours et et sa vision du sujet de
l'engagement des femmes en zone rurale
avec un versus cette fois-ci délu local
dans une collectivité rurale Christine
qui est sur la parole
bonjour monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'archet madame la sénatrice madame
billon mesdames messenatrices mesdames
les sénateurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
élus tout d'abord je voudrais exprimer
avec la mère de donc de la forêt un
petit village aussi des Hautes-Alpes
toute notre déception de ne pas être
avec vous physiquement voilà par
ailleurs j'ai un petit peu de
malentendre donc voilà de m'en excuser
donc je me présente je suis pressing
maxima donc la suppliante du sénateur
Jean-Michel Arnaud et fier de l'être je
suis par ailleurs maire donc d'un petit
Baratier je vous remercie de retenir le
nom un petit village où donc des
Hautes-Alpes près de du lac de
Serre-Ponçon à proximité du National des
Écrins du parc national de régional du
Pirat bref un petit village et un
département magnifique
d'ailleurs je suis également
vice-présidente du de la communauté de
communes de Serre-Ponçon qui regroupe 17
communes donc avec
17000 habitants alors mon parcours
d'élus
d'abord je suis très très attaché à mon
village passionné par mon département le
pays des Hautes-Alpes que je me suis
investie très très jeune
pour l'intérêt général en suivant la
génération de
mes parents et dans la vie du village et
18 ans j'ai créé cofondé et j'étais
cofondatrice et co-animatrice d'une
association de qui regroupait tous les
jeunes du village et qui avait pour
mission la responsabilisation des de des
jeunes à travers l'animation de leur
village en fait cette investissement
cette implication je pense ma
prédisposée à jusqu'à 21 ans je me
présentais
en tant que candidate libre avec deux
autres dames plus âgées que moi aux
élections municipales nous n'avons pas
été élu voilà donc voilà j'ai continué à
m'intéresser à la vie locale publique
j'étais stagiaire à un moment donné de
la commune sur un projet de
développement local est-ce que tu peux
faire attention de ne pas toucher ton
micro parce qu'on a du grésillement qui
est un inconfort pour nous merci
donc
par ailleurs donc de formation de
responsable dans les secteurs
socio-éducatifs de loisirs et culturel
je me suis aussi investie
professionnellement dans la vie locale
donc notamment dans le tourisme
l'encadrement de groupe bon ce n'était
pas facile parce que la ruralité ne
permet pas toujours l'accès aux emplois
en lien avec nos notre niveau d'études
et puis j'ai continué donc en 1989 par
contre on est on m'a proposé de
candidater sur une liste de de communal
donc j'ai été j'étais élue pour la
première fois
j'étais donc la plus jeune et pour
certains élus j'étais aussi certains
administrés la petite fille qu'ils
avaient vu grandir donc sans compter
qu'à cette époque peu de femmes avait
encore des responsabilités dans la vie
publique et dans la vie professionnelle
et peut-être avec moins d'ouverture
d'esprit dans dans la ruralité je me
revois lors du premier conseil municipal
je n'osais pas prendre la parole pour me
donner de l'assurance et de la
crédibilité j'ai énormément travaillé je
me suis dit j'ai continué à m'engager
aux élections suivantes je suis arrivée
à une voix d'humeur et donc une voie du
maire sortant et donc le maire a créé un
poste de troisième adjointe spécialement
pour moi
ensuite et bien j'ai été élu premier
adjointe durant les trois dernières
mandatures il y avait entre deux et
quatre femmes pour 11 élus et le dernier
mandat 4 femmes pour pour 15 ans je me
rendais compte que les que les femmes
avaient souvent une vision différente
elle rentrait plus dans les détails à
s'investir à être dans le collectif sans
pour attendre en retour une valorisation
durant toutes ces mandatures je me suis
mais vraiment énormément impliquée
j'étais là donc la seule adjointe j'ai
travaillé avec beaucoup de persistance
pour me donner de la crédibilité comme
peut-être d'autres femmes je devais
peut-être démontrer démontrer un
professionnel peut-être à porter ma
valeur ajoutée la commune je n'ai pas eu
vraiment de difficulté de relation avec
les avec les hommes parfois bien sûr je
devais hausser le la voix pour me faire
entendre mais je crois que en fait ma
position de femme m'a réussi on me
laissait faire certains me regardaient
faire clairement il me semblait normal
que en tant que femme que je sois plus
contributif que je révise peut-être plus
d'activités que d'autres élus hommes on
me laissait faire certains me
regardaient faire mais j'ai eu
l'opportunité de présenter des dossiers
sur la table de pouvoir réaliser des
actions des projets qui ne tenaient à
coeur pour l'intérêt de mon village de
mon territoire en entraînant toute
l'équipe et ça je crois que c'était
vraiment le pour moi l'essentiel c'était
le mon engagement était le plus fort
ensuite j'ai été élu donc en mai 2020
donc maire de ma commune de mon village
c'était vraiment très fier une grande
fierté voilà je l'ai mis une priorité
notamment la parité dans la constitution
de ma liste donc j'ai cette femme cette
homme et même si la parité n'était pas
obligatoire je le souhaite donc j'ai
deux adjoints
j'ai deux adjoints hommes et deux
adjoints femmes dont la première femme
est une est une
femme j'avais fait aussi appel à un
organisme de formation pour former
l'équipe
sur le rôle de la commune et de l'équipe
qui l'anime je voulais vraiment que que
chacune et chacun prenne sa place pleine
et entière qui est vraiment une
solidarité entre l'équipe et qui est
surtout pas de différence entre les
entre les élus
les délégations qui étaient
[Musique]
habituellement attribué aux femmes
sociales éducation ou attribués aux
hommes travaux
finances etc ont été attribués en
fonction des appétences de chacun j'ai
trois élus qui constituent la commission
école j'ai un référence qui est qui
s'occupe du poêle en France jeunesse de
la commune j'ai une femme qui est lu
référente sur les dossiers glissement de
terrain risque naturel la première
adjointe s'occupe de la sécurité des
personnes et des espaces bref des hommes
et des femmes en majorité jeune et
seulement deux retraités des hommes et
des femmes qui gagnent d'horizons
différentes il y a de la bienveillance
et du respect entre entre chaque élu
femme et homme nous organisons des
réunions en visioconférence pour gagner
du temps pour caler les horaires en
fonction des
disponibilités de chacun j'ai des
premier j'ai une maman avec un jeune
enfant nous travaillons et changeons
beaucoup par mail pour ne pas perdre de
temps
voilà et par ailleurs je suis donc élue
vice-présidente de la communauté de
communes de Serre-Ponçon comme je vous
l'ai dit donc le 17000 habitants 17
communes et nous sommes seulement trois
mères femmes dont la présidence est
également aussi la deuxième
vice-présidente de la Région alors la
gouvernance des EPCI ne permet pas la
parité un seul représentant par commune
rurale
je pense que les choses évoluent il faut
continuer je pense qu'il faut pousser la
parité pour les communes de moins de
1000 habitants
je pense qu'il faut aussi assurer une
meilleure représentativité des femmes au
niveau de l'échelle intercommunale
il faut aussi inciter les femmes à
s'engager dans la vie politique en
assurant une meilleure articulation des
temps de vie il faut également aussi
assurer une formation des élus dès la
prise de fonction
en qualité également de substance du
sénateur sur le département j'accompagne
le travail de qualité mené par le
sénateur donc sur ces questions après
les tables rondes que nous avons
organisé en 2021
notamment dans le cadre du rapport femme
et ruralité en finir avec les zones
blanches nous avions d'ailleurs organisé
table ronde et notamment une table ronde
sur la participation des des femmes donc
à la vie politique locale où nous avions
recueilli des témoignages vraiment à
valeur d'exemple et il faut continuer
donc à faire venir aujourd'hui je
souhaite aux côtés du sénateurs mettre
en place des actions d'information et de
communication auprès des collectivités
locales afin d'informer les élus sur
tous les
dispositifs et les structures qui
pour permettre
concernant les femmes qui sont victimes
de violence voilà en conclusion je
dirais que je suis très fier d'être très
fier d'être une femme élue fier de
m'investir pour pour l'intérêt de mon
village de mon territoire je pense que
la différence d'approche de sensibilité
entre les hommes et les femmes
va créer une complémentarité de vision
et qui va servir l'intérêt de du
territoire c'est vraiment une richesse
très importante je pense que dans les
faits nous sommes plus nous sommes plus
persistantes sans vraiment chercher des
entre guillemets des lauriers nous
sommes dans le collectif dans l'intérêt
général nous sommes capables d'une
stratégie à long terme et en même temps
aussi on rentre dans les détails et pas
uniquement dans le faire faire mais
aussi dans le faire si nécessaire je
pense qu'il faut continuer à travailler
sur les nombreuses contraintes qui
restreignent l'envie des femmes à
accéder à la vie politique il faut
donner envie aux femmes de s'engager
leur donner des moyens en tout cas c'est
une belle place et il faut il faut la
valoriser je dirais aussi en conclusion
donc la parité entre comme l'égalité
hommes et femmes dans le dans la vie
économique et sociale
progressera aussi par exemple arrêter de
nos collectivités voilà je vous remercie
de m'avoir écouté
bien merci merci Madame le Maire est
venu le temps de vous donner la parole
en remerciant à la fois Christiane
Lambert et Christine de leur témoignage
liminaire qui souhaitent prendre la
parole réagir ou ou produire produire
une suggestion
madame je vous en prie présentez-vous
oui bonjour Martine nous serions mère
danser 356 habitants dans la Vienne le
département de Bruno Belin je suis aussi
vice-présidente en charge de l'enfance
et de la jeunesse à ma communauté de
communes du civrayé en Poitou membre du
Comité européen des régions depuis un an
et aussi enseignante dans un lycée
agricole auprès des apprentis en bac pro
et donc je voulais réagir tout
simplement à l'intervention de Madame
Lambert concernant les jeunes filles qui
sont en lycée agricole alors moi ce que
je peux vous dire de mon expérience qui
est quand même de 37 ans maintenant
puisque nous avons à peu près le même
âge et bien c'est que des jeunes filles
elles sont moteurs dans les classes je
n'ai pas toujours de filles dans mes
classes ça arrive encore dans les
classes de bac pro mais quand il y en a
je sais que la classe va travailler
et ça je vous assure que c'est vrai et
même il m'est arrivé une réflexion d'un
garçon un jour je disais bon est-ce que
tu as pris il me dit mais madame je suis
pas une fille est-ce que tu as pris tes
notes madame je suis pas une fille et il
demande à la fille aux filles parce
qu'elles sont rarement quand même plus
de trois ou quatre sur des sections de
24 de les aider souvent j'ai demandé à
Manuela j'ai demandé à Laura etc donc
moi j'ai tout à fait confiance dans ces
jeunes filles et je vois qu'après quand
je suis un petit peu quand elle sont
sorties de du bac pro elles vont embts
elles vont encore plus loin ce sont
elles qui prennent les responsabilités
et je suis sûr que le monde agricole
dans les années à venir contrat encore
plus sur ces jeunes filles qui vont
devenir agricultrice ou d'autres métiers
dans ce secteur voilà c'est juste je
voulais vous dire ça
merci
je vous remercie votre témoignage
d'autres d'autres interventions
je souhaiterais peut-être
dans une intervention de Madame le Maire
de la fonction publique notamment
j'aurais souhaité la place des femmes
dans l'entreprise mais aussi dans la
fonction publique et à ce moment-là
comme il faut mettre en valeur le
travail de la délégation je vais je vais
donner la parole à Martin filleul qui a
été co-rapporteur pour avec Dominique
Verrien et il y aura une proposition de
loi qui va arriver au Sénat
prochainement le 5 avril et qui vise à
fermenter les femmes dans la en
responsabilité dans la fonction publique
donc il est bien entendu question du
seuil des mille habitants et en
interpellera peut-être une autre élue
présente dans la salle avec Jean-Michel
Arnaud mais j'aurais aimé éventuellement
que notre collègue qui va se faire le
porte-voix de de Dominique verrière à la
fois nous nous parle un petit peu de ce
texte qui arrive au Sénat et qui
intéresse le gouvernement puisque on
avait travaillé sur les que l'égalité
économique et professionnelle mais on
travaille aussi parce qu'il est question
du privé et pourquoi ne pas se soucier
du public à vous chers collègues madame
la Cora porteur Martine filliel oui
merci madame la Présidente de me donner
la parole sur un dossier effectivement
qui me tient à cœur qui est celui de la
fonction publique et de l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes dans la
fonction publique parce que moi-même
j'ai appartenu à cette fonction publique
et j'ai vraiment je voudrais vraiment
qu'elle soit exemplaire et en fait on
s'aperçoit en travaillant sur le sujet
qu'on est loin du compte en réalité et
que la loi sauvadée qui a dit il y a 10
ans avez voulu justement faire
progresser cette parité dans la fonction
publique et bien n'a pas donné tous les
résultats attendus elle a permis certes
de progresser pour ce qui concerne les
postes les plus importants
ce qu'on appelle la haute fonction
publique mais même pas j'allais dire de
manière satisfaisante puisque je le
disais hier dans une émission de Public
Sénat il y a encore des ministères ceux
qui traditionnellement sont masculins le
ministère des armées le ministère des
Finances bien qui ne remplissent pas
leur obligation de parité dans les
postes de de la haute fonction publique
et cela va vous surprendre je pense P
des amendes parce qu'il n'obéissent pas
à la loi un million d'euros payés par
les ministères parce qu'ils ne répondent
pas aux obligations de la loi c'est
vraiment très surprenant ça mérite
d'être reconnu mais comme
j'allais dire même s'il y a une certaine
transparence il faut fouiller un peu
dans les lois de finances publiques pour
se rendre compte que les ministères
eux-mêmes paient des amendes parce
qu'ils ne pas à la loi donc nous avons
avec ma collègue Dominique Verrien
proposé des modes d'approfondissement
d'amélioration de cette loi sauvadée et
en particulier
pour ne pas prendre la parole trop
longtemps il me semble qu'il y a deux
dimensions vraiment importantes c'est
l'augmentation du périmètre des postes
concernés par cette égalité homme-femme
nous proposons que 20 000 postes soient
concernés dans la fonction publique qui
feront l'objet d'une observation
et est une d'une appréciation et
également nous avons proposé d'instaurer
un index de la parité comme il en existe
dans donc dans le privé un index bon qui
n'est pas complètement satisfaisant mais
et qui va s'améliorer je l'espère au fur
et à mesure du temps et ce serait bien
que la fonction publique soit également
concernée par cet index pour qu'on
progresse valablement et de manière
j'allais dire
d'une manière bien contrôlée également
voilà je vous remercie madame la
Présidente j'ai pas voulu être trop
longue mais effectivement si ce sujet
vous intéresse sachez que cette
proposition de loi sera donc présentée
dans l'hémicycle le 5 avril et vraiment
vous êtes invité à participer au débat
ce sera avec plaisir merci
merci chers collègues nous y serons je
crois que il y avait lors de
l'intervention sur l'obligation de la
parité notamment dans les conseils
municipaux de moins 1000 habitants
quelques réactions je crois madame vous
vouliez émettre une réflexion à ce sujet
voilà c'est chers
de la commune de Rognac dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône et j'ai aussi la
coprésidence au niveau de l'Association
des maires de France sur plusieurs
commissions notamment éducation sport
les droits de la femme et la sécurité je
m'interrogeais juste par moment sur la
notion de quota notamment de passer ça
met un petit peu difficile de passer par
une notion de quantitatif et non pas de
qualitatif pour pouvoir exister dans les
instances
je le dis c'est vrai que j'aurais
souhaité quand même qu'on associe
toujours la femme à la compétence et non
pas se dire qu'on est un nombre pourquoi
parce que je fais pas de féminisme
j'allais dire qu'il tomberait dans un de
l'extrême ou abusif je suis sur un
féminisme c'est assez universaliste de
dire qu'il y a aussi des collègues
compétents hommes qui lorsqu'on fait les
listes et bien nous sommes contraints de
les voir finir leur mandat peut-être au
détriment où on fait de la recherche de
femmes de profil tout simplement donc ça
m'a toujours un petit peu ébranlé de
voir qu'on en était là
encore dans un pays où normalement on
devrait plus être là la femme est
compétente elle a sa place l'homme est
complétant et compétent il a sa place
mais on voit que la méritocratie recule
dans tous les domaines pas qu'au niveau
de la parité et au niveau des quotas de
moins de 1000 habitants il y a des
grandes difficultés déjà à composer pour
les confrères et ça remonte à
l'Association des maires de France de
déjà de faire une liste tout court
et donc je me dis que dire rajouter une
contrainte est-ce qu'on va atteindre
l'objectif donc je suis on est toujours
on s'interroge sur est-ce que c'est
facilitateur de se rajouter un paramètre
dans certains secteurs on a déjà tout
simplement du mal à trouver des élus des
hommes et des femmes qui veulent
s'engager dans les fonctions qui sont
les nôtres aujourd'hui dans le contexte
qui est notre aussi je veux dire c'est
difficile être élu de la République
aujourd'hui de n'importe quel instant ce
qu'on soit qu'on soit un parlementaire
qu'on soit les fantassins dans les
pouvoirs décentralisés le contexte qui
soit économique social et sociétales
peuvent faire peur peut faire peur à
l'engagement donc je suis toujours très
inquiète qu'on rajoute une voilà je
faisais juste part de l'inquiétude qui
avait déjà été évoquée au niveau de la
MF
bien merci de ce témoignage de la merde
Rognac je vais laisser Christine
Christiane pardon Lambert qui a souhaité
réagir à votre témoignage le soin de
s'exprimer
merci
suite à ce que viennent suite à ce que
vous venez de dire nous nous sommes
posés la question dans les mêmes termes
c'est à dire que
c'est parfois mal perçu par certaines
femmes que de dire il faut des quotas
pour qu'ils puissent y avoir des femmes
c'est par contre il est vrai que quand
on monte dans les dans les
responsabilités et les lieux de
responsabilité élevées il peut y avoir
de la concurrence et ça peut être mal
perçu de bloquer comme ils disent pour
les femmes et le parti pris que nous
avons pris à la FNSEA c'est de dire que
nous allions faire le maximum pour
donner les passes possibilités de
prendre des responsabilités c'est-à-dire
mettre en place des formations
accompagnées par le remplacement
vis-à-vis des enfants vis-à-vis de
travail dans l'exploitation
peut-être aussi confié des dossiers qui
correspondent plus et j'ai beaucoup
apprécié le témoignage de Madame le
Maire qui a dit que les femmes étaient
peut-être plus dans le détail dans la
précision pour pas faire non maîtriser
les sujets donc c'est sur des sujets
très complexes et techniques c'est pas
pour rien que dans notre milieu les
femmes sont très engagées sur les sujets
sociaux et fiscaux qui sont d'une grande
complexité qui sont d'importance
politique mais qui nécessitent de
maîtriser parfaitement tous les détails
pour faire les bonnes négociations et
donc on n'a pas fait le choix de quotas
et j'espère qu'on réussit à malgré tout
donc on a des femmes qui arrivent
aujourd'hui sur des postes où elle
n'était pas auparavant en responsabilité
sur des grandes productions animales ou
sur des dossiers de sanitaire etc mais
je vois que comme chez vous c'est très
débattu mais on n'a pas penché du côté
quota
oui je crois que Valérie Boyer sénatrice
des Bouches-du-Rhône veut prendre la
parole je dirais juste si vous permettez
en transition que ce débat évidemment
nous les avons eu ils sont pas tranchés
nous l'avons tranché dans les
conclusions du rapport avec du
volontarisme je tiens aussi à porter un
témoignage que vous avez toutes et tous
vécu entre la première instauration des
assemblées départementales paritaires et
le renouvellement de ces assemblées
paritaires en a progressé il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui à quelques rares exceptions
près de contestation du fait qu'il y ait
un binôme homme-femme dans les conseils
départementaux et nous voyons y compris
glisser positivement les responsabilités
des dames vers des exécutifs et vers des
thématiques exercées dans les conseils
départementaux en matière exécutifs qui
s'élargissent sur des métiers qui
n'étaient pas restreint les affaires
sociales éducation qui n'était pas
restreint
aux seules hommes aux seules femmes donc
je pense que malgré tout les choses
progressent Valérie
c'est un mot pour dire qu'il y a quand
même un phénomène qui existe depuis 1965
il y a plus de femmes qui ont le bac que
d'hommes les femmes sont beaucoup plus
diplômées que les hommes
et donc ça c'est une réalité extrêmement
importante effectivement être réduite au
quota et particulièrement agaçant je
suis bien d'accord mais compte tenu de
la formation et ça a été souligné
ça ça explique aussi la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
mais moi juste une petite remarque je
suis toujours touchée émue
mais c'est curieux à chaque fois qu'on
demande à une femme de témoigner de son
parcours elle va parler des grands
événements de sa vie professionnelle
mais il y a toujours les maternités qui
interviennent et ça nous met quand même
au coeur du sujet c'est vrai que c'est
des dates très importantes dans la vie
d'une famille mais quand un homme parle
de son CV il a rarement il a rarement
les moments où il est devenu papa et ça
montre combien la situation des femmes
des mères de famille et aujourd'hui la
conciliation de la vie professionnelle
et de la vie
familiale et extrêmement importante mais
surtout je crois qu'on devrait vraiment
réfléchir à la violence qui est faite
aux jeunes femmes aujourd'hui qui sont
contraintes de choisir entre travailler
ou avoir des enfants et qui repoussent
leur grossesse qui se prive d'un du
deuxième du troisième du quatrième parce
que notre société n'est pas accueillante
pour les femmes qui choisissent d'avoir
des enfants et de travailler et je crois
que c'est une réflexion globale qu'on
soit en ruralité
en ville ailleurs c'est un choix mais ce
choix on doit l'accompagner choisir de
ne pas en avoir est un choix tout à fait
respectable mais choisir d'en avoir
nécessite je crois une réflexion
extrêmement importante que nous n'avons
pas parce que on a considéré que
l'émancipation ça passait probablement
par le choix de ne pas en avoir mais
l'émancipation c'est aussi avoir la
liberté d'avoir des enfants et de
travailler totalement et c'est un sujet
qui traverse toutes les zones qu'elles
soient urbaines rurales etc c'était tout
ce que je voulais dire merci beaucoup de
ces témoignages
ça change
il y a des de plus en plus de pairs qui
prennent un congé paternité mon fils est
né qui travaille chez erson young
cabinet conseil fiscal etc il a fait le
choix de lui de prendre sa femme et
fonctionnaire mais c'est lui qui a pris
un des paternité ça de la coopération
agricole je m'étonnais qu'un dossier
n'avance pas comme il devait avancer
j'ai appris que le garçon qu'on avait la
responsabilité après un congé paternité
donc il y a aussi des pères qui prennent
maintenant le nouveau père je ne
génération alors c'est peut-être les
moins de 30 ans donc ça va mettre un peu
de temps à diffuser et là je vous
rejoins c'est que nous la femme nous
sommes habitués à avoir des vies
séquencées vous voyez dans mon parcours
j'ai plus j'ai refusé certaines
responsabilités comme mon deuxième est
arrivé j'ai pas voulu aller sur Paris
parce qu'il est je voulais un deuxième
et puis après j'ai réorganisé ma vie
séquencé par rapport aux maternité et
par rapport mon choix d'arrêter mes
responsabilités aujourd'hui il y a plein
d'hommes qui me disent mais qu'est-ce
que tu vas faire comme si on était perdu
quand on avait plus une fonction manger
une maison un mari des enfants une
reprise d'exploitation qui se prépare
j'ai plein j'ai deux petits enfants
aujourd'hui on peut avoir des projets et
un agenda plus choisi en ayant un peu
plus de temps disponible aussi la
difficulté en responsabilité élevée
c'est que on est sur un agenda qui est
un rail tracé écrit jusqu'au samedi et
on a plus aucun temps de de
respiration et cette faire ce choix là
je me rends compte que c'est les femmes
qu'est-ce que tu as raison c'est bien
etc c'est courageux etc mais les hommes
disent surtout mais qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire tu vas t'ennuyer alors en riant je
leur dis je vais tricoter alors je suis
absolument pas tricoté mais
une vie de responsabilité pendant 40 ans
pour certains après c'est la rupture et
le grand plouf non il peut y avoir
d'autres choses après madame Lambert
revendique à sa manière le droit la
paresse c'était quand même un élément
intéressant
je vous taquine
je taquine madame madame la Présidente
je vous laisse la parole bonjour moi je
suis Madame Claudet Isabelle maire d'une
commune de 425 habitants en
Franche-Comté en Bourgogne
moi je suis devenu vert par hasard parce
que je n'ai pas l'impression que les
trois quarts des gens qui sont devenus
maires étaient déjà premier adjoint
deuxième adjoint etc moi j'étais
adjointe dans l'opposition dans une
grosse mairie un Angi en Seigneur même
de plus de 7000 habitants je suis
arrivée en Bourgogne il y a deux ans
avant de devenir mère donc on peut vous
dire un petit peu que je connaissais
absolument personne la liste a été
montée par l'ancienne mère et moi ce qui
me gêne le plus dans mon travail de mère
c'est le manque de formation qu'on peut
avoir
et là c'est vraiment très gênant pour
vous expliquer un petit peu moi je suis
arrivée donc Merlin en 2020
la secrétaire qui était là depuis des
années et partie en vacances puis en
congé maladie et je l'ai jamais revu
et là ça a été super galère aussi pour
trouver une autre secrétaire de mairie
qui vaille le coup qui soit formé qui
puisse m'épauler donc j'en ai trouvé une
autre mais qu'on n'est pas le secteur
donc c'est un peu compliqué aussi donc
voyez là c'est c'est plus ça quoi et
puis au niveau de la côté de commune on
est donc 19 communes on est que deux
femmes donc je trouve que c'est pas
beaucoup parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
des avis des façons de voir sur des
choses très différentes par rapport aux
hommes et je pense que c'est pas inutile
et puis je voulais rebondir aussi un
petit peu sur le manque de compétences
ou autre moi je trouve qu'à partir du
moment on a la volonté on peut arriver à
tout à partir du moment où on veut faire
les choses on veut s'investir on veut
faire avancer les choses et bien on va
trouver les moyens de se former les
moyens de même si c'est un peu galère
voilà c'est bon mon témoignage merci
Madame le Maire de votre témoignage
Annick billon
merci Monsieur le Cora porteur merci à
vous tous déjà pour ce témoignages
intéressants ce que je voudrais dire par
rapport aux remarques sur les quotas
personne n'a envie de quota en fait
personne n'a envie d'imposer la seule
chose c'est que on sait très bien que si
il n'y a pas des quotas il y a pas des
obligations on n'avance pas voir on
recule donc pour ma part il y a 22 ans
je suis rentrée dans une commune parce
que de plus de 1000 habitants
l'obligation avec la révision
constitutionnelle d'avoir une liste
paritaire donc si on fait aussi écho au
monde de l'entreprise la loi
copézimmermann l'obligation dans les
conseils d'administration des conseils
de surveillance on avait dit qu'on
trouverait pas il y avait pas le vivier
il y avait pas suffisamment de femmes
pour siéger et bien c'est pas un
problème une fois que il y a la
contrainte on est devenu les meilleurs
au niveau international en termes de
présence de femmes dans ces conseils
d'administration conseil de surveillance
dans les grandes entreprises donc charge
femme de s'engager charge aux femmes une
fois qu'elles sont en poste de de
montrer toutes leurs compétences et d'y
travailler et puis après les choses se
font naturellement donc hier nous avions
le président Gérard Larcher avec les 11
ministres nous avions invité au Sénat 11
ministres femmes et c'est ce qu'il
expliquait aussi donc oui quand même à
de l'obligation sans obligation de
progresse pas et comme nous avions la
chance d'avoir Valérie Letard
vice-présidente du Sénat tout à l'heure
je remercie également notre président de
la Délégation aux collectivités
Françoise Gatel sénatrice
d'Ille-et-Vilaine qui nous a rejoint et
j'aimerais qu'elle nous touche un mot
sur évidemment les collectivités
l'engagement au féminin et peut-être sa
vision des contraintes des freins
puisque forcément dans une
intercommunalité désormais là où le
pouvoir se trouve et bien les postes à
responsabilité ce sont les mers et ce
qui est bien logique sauf il y a moins
de femmes mère il y a moins de
représentations des femmes dans ces
lieux de pouvoir madame la Présidente
chère Françoise à vous pour clôturer
cette table ronde et je laisserai
ensuite conclure monsieur le Cora
porteur Jean-Michel Arnaud merci madame
la Présidente
merci à vous tous je connais
quelques-uns parmi vous je suis heureuse
de saluer Christiane Lambert moi j'aime
bien la manière dont elle parle
c'est-à-dire les femmes peuvent choisir
leur temps de vie on peut être très
heureux en ayant un engagement un peu
fort avec des responsabilités et on peut
être très heureux en s'intéressant à
d'autres sujets et bien que ça puisse
vous puissiez le dire et c'est assez
fascinant qui est des regards encore un
peu étonnés sur votre éventuelle envie
de tricoter quoi ce qui n'est ce qui
n'est pas le cas merci
Annick Jean-Michel Marie-Pierre Monnier
et les autres alors le sujet de de la
parité dans les collectivités
territoriales on sait bien que c'est un
vrai sujet à la délégation collectivité
que j'ai l'honneur de présider on
s'interroge beaucoup en se rappelant que
l'objectif final c'est l'efficacité de
l'action publique
et que nous nous pensons que il y a
plage pour tous les citoyens et on voit
bien au sein d'un conseil municipal
qu'on le compose dans la diversité de
nos citoyens puisque un conseil
municipal c'est un échantillon
représentatif de la population donc il y
a des gens de quartiers différents d'âge
différents il doit y avoir des femmes
qui doivent avoir leur place alors
aujourd'hui effectivement on peut encore
regretter qu'il y ait des quotas mais je
pense que si elle est pas de
d'incitation
les choses
n'auraient pas forcément permis aux
femmes qui ont envie de s'engager de
pouvoir le faire
et que moi j'ai été lu mère parce que
j'ai eu envie et je suis devenue
présidente de mon interco par hasard et
je dois vous le dire grâce aux hommes
alors pourquoi c'est parce qu'aucun des
hommes qui témèrent ne voulait y aller
parce que c'est un peu compliqué et donc
ils mangent gentiment dit
Françoise thémère de la plus grande
ville fructiya et puis tu connais pas
l'histoire bon bah moi j'y suis allé
voilà on s'en est sorti et aujourd'hui
je trouve ça un peu un peu amusant comme
un anecdote mais ça reste encore
un lieu de difficulté peut-être
l'intercom mais surtout les syndicats
et quand j'entends des collègues
défendre la parité dans les bureaux
exécutifs des intercos j'en parlerai moi
je dis allons regarder du côté des
syndicats connaissez-vous trois femmes
qui sont présidents de syndicats de
collecte et de traitement d'ordures
ménagères ou de syndicat des eaux
alors il doit bien en avoir trois mais
aujourd'hui ça reste encore des postes à
responsabilité
éminemment masculin il faut y aller voir
du côté des syndicats qui sont aussi des
lieux
d'importance moi ce que j'ai constaté
aussi quand je suis devenue présidente
de l'Association des mères c'est la
différence de culture assez spontanée
des femmes une femme qui devient mère
elle prend son téléphone elle va avoir
une collègue on se fait déminéraires en
disant tiens moi j'ai ce sujet comment
tu as fait vous voyez il y a cette idée
que on est moi je dis pas plus ouvert
mais en tout cas on n'a pas forcément un
égo surpuissant on a surtout l'envie de
d'être utile de réussir ici la collègue
a réussi à résoudre le problème
on ne va pas avoir l'air
comment dire un peu nul si on va lui
demander au contraire ça va nous faire
gagner du temps et être efficace et puis
je trouve
ça dû vous arriver quand vous montez une
liste et que vous allez chercher des
femmes
souvent elles mais pourquoi tu aimes
chercher enfin moi voilà ah non mais tu
comprends moi je veux pas avoir le temps
faut bosser j'avoue que cette question
je passe faire dans t'imagines mais
j'avoue que cette question je l'ai plus
souvent entendue
de la part d'une femme et d'un homme
maintenant je pense qu'il faut
encourager les femmes à devenir mère ou
adjoint c'est extrêmement important et
comment on fait
j'entends la question de madame qui
représentait l'Association des maires de
France moi j'ai cette question est-ce
qu'on va chercher la parité dans les
communes de moins de 1000
est-ce qu'on la pose je pense que les
quotas doivent pas empêcher
l'efficacité que moi on me dit si vous
faites des listes paritaires dans les
communes de moins de 1000 la démocratie
est finie parce qu'on trouve pas de
monde
il y aura pas de seconde liste je dis on
nous a déjà dit ça quand on a fait la
liste à 1000 maintenant je pense qu'il
faut regarder et que peut-être faut-il
parallèlement diminuer le nombre de
conseillers municipaux moi j'entends
quand vous avez des communes ça existe
de 40 ou 50 habitants vous devez avoir
un nombre de conseils municipaux
importants vous les avez au début mais
ensuite vous les perdez un peu et c'est
tellement vrai que dans la dernière
langue la journée proximité enfin trois
lettres on a reconnu qu'un conseil
municipal pouvait ne pas être complet
pour faciliter l'engagement des femmes
ça a été dit quand vous travaillez vous
avez des enfants vous avez un conjoint
qui bosse c'est un peu compliqué d'avoir
des réunions le soir et de s'engager je
rappelle que dans la loi engagement et
proximité on a inventé un truc un peu
nouveau c'est la prise en charge par les
communes des frais de garde d'enfant
parce que je pense que on doit pouvoir
aussi permettre aux femmes de s'engager
et qu'il faut pas que la vie personnelle
soit soit un frein ensuite je pense
qu'il y a un sujet cela a été évoqué sur
la formation
au début moi quand j'étais lumère alors
on avait une formation finance voilà moi
je pense qu'aformation finale comme il y
a de moins en moins d'argent de toute
façon donc elle est formée aux finances
bon bref je pense que c'est important
c'est une formation technique mais être
formé par les associations des lieux à
la gestion d'équipe à la relation avec
le personnel ça c'est extrêmement
important il faut donner aux maires
comme aux hommes la capacité à bien
trouver sa place et à le faire ensuite
un mot sur la question de la parité dans
les intercos et dans les exécutifs
moi je n'ai jamais dit oui à ça alors je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi c'est mon
expérience de présidente d'Interco
pousser qui m'a amené à dire ça je pense
que dans nos intercommunalités il y a
des réalités extrêmement différentes et
que si on dit que dans l'exécutif doit
avoir de la parité ça va vous poser
souvent un gros problème de démocratie
parce que si vous choisissez d'organiser
votre exécutif communautaire en fonction
des compétences des gens parce que vous
voulez avoir tous les mers au bureau par
exemple
et bien si vous avez des communes où le
maire n'est pas une femme vous allez
l'écarter et bien imaginez la relation
que vous allez avoir avec la commune
qui est la seule à ne pas avoir son
maire au bureau moi je pense que c'est
difficile donc je pense que la façon d'y
arriver au niveau de l'interco c'est
vraiment d'encourager les femmes à
devenir mère et de leur permettre d'être
sur des fonctions qui sont des fonctions
universelles enfin moi je pense pas
qu'un homme est plus compétent pour
réaliser une voie qu'une femme au
contraire j'ai vu des femmes parce
qu'elles empruntaient la voie du village
et qu'une poussette ou cachez pas quoi
non mais là ce serait bien qu'on fasse
un bateau parce qu'on va avoir un
problème quoi bon voilà donc je pense
qu'il y a une intelligence
complémentaire et que sur la parité dans
les exécutifs communautaires il faut
vraiment la gagner à partir de
l'augmentation d'une
ombre de mer parce que il y a parfois un
moment où la meilleure intention du
monde paralyse un peu je vais terminer
par un exemple qui est celui d'une PPL
qui arrive la semaine prochaine vous
savez que dans les dans les communes de
plus de 1000 les délégués les
conseillers communautaires sont fléchés
d'accord et vous êtes fléchés par sexe
et donc aujourd'hui dans votre interco
il se peut que votre commune n'est plus
la représentation qu'elle devait avoir
votre commune à loi par exemple à trois
conseillers communautaires l'opposition
à 1 et bien si entre guillemets votre
stock d'homme ou de femmes étaient
épuisé vous ne pouvez pas aller chercher
un homme ou une femme qui a beau avoir
été fléchés parce que celui qui a
démissionné ou qui était parti était un
homme et vous n'êtes plus que des femmes
donc je pense que on va proposer qu'il y
ait une continuité de représentation en
disant une femme égale un homme c'est
bien l'objet de notre journée donc voilà
merci merci à tous en tout cas merci de
ces échanges et de votre engagement
bien
merci merci Françoise la première
séquence de notre matinée vient à sa fin
nous allons enchaîner avec Marie-pierre
qui va nous parler des jeunes dans les
territoires ruraux et comment élargir
les champs des possibles je terminerai
simplement cette partie de la matinée en
prenant une formule qui a été
proclamée tout à l'heure par Christine
Maximin pour rester sur un ton positif
et constructif il s'agit finalement de
travailler
ensemble hommes et femmes dans la
différence de nos sensibilités mais dans
la complémentarité de nos visions et je
crois que c'est l'objectif que nous
devons avoir pour
l'efficacité nos politiques publiques
dans nos territoires je vous remercie en
tous les cas votre participation qui
s'est élargi par l'arrivée d'un grand
nombre de collègues élus locaux et nous
sommes heureux donc de voir et de sentir
votre participation à votre intérêt pour
les thématiques
qui nous réunissent ce matin je vous
remercie
et bien bonjour à toutes et tous
je salue madame la Présidente cher
Annick chère Jean-Michel et Christian
Lambert que nous avions auditionné pour
un rapport sur femme etriculture que je
vous invite à aller voir les lire voir
sur le site du Sénat et qui était fort
intéressant merci pour vos témoignages
et vos informations je vous salue
mesdames et messieurs j'aime à dire
souvent que la question d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes n'est pas
qu'une question de femme ni de féminisme
c'est tout simplement une égalité entre
deux êtres humains entre des êtres
humains et que nous ne pouvons pas nous
les femmes être les seuls à porter ce
sujet-là et nous devons le faire tout et
tous ensemble j'avais envie de réagir un
petit peu sur vos propos d'abord vous
dire que nous sommes
51,6% de femmes je crois que c'est en 19
derniers chiffres que nous avons nous
aussi un cerveau et que nous sommes
capables et je crois que c'est un bel
exemple que vous soyez là aujourd'hui
femme qui s'emmer et adjointe et quand
c'est municipales et concernanticipal je
crois qu'il faut multiplier nous le
faisons souvent au Sénat mais tous les
moments des gens qui montrent que nous
sommes capables d'être à la tête d'une
commune à la tête d'une enquête terre
courte à la tête d'un département à la
tête d'une région ou au parlementaire et
que il faut multiplier ces exemples là
parce que moi c'est comme madame je suis
arrivé en politique tout à fait par
hasard et c'est je dis toujours je suis
un pur produit de la parité sans la
parité et l'obligation des parité je ne
serai pas là il a bien fallu qu'il
vienne chercher une femme parce qu'il
fallait que le thème de liste bref tout
ça pour dire que ce que vous faites est
important pour votre commune mais pour
les femmes qui sont dans vos communes
parce que ça montre que c'est possible
et qu'on est capable de diriger une
commune et donc surtout ne lâchez rien
et je terminerai avant de commencer mes
propos par une citation de Françoise
Giroud parce qu'on a parlé pas mal tout
à l'heure pas mal de compétences en 1983
qui disait la femme sera vraiment légale
de l'homme le jour où un poste important
on désirera une femme incompétente parce
que nous les femmes on besoin et parler
parlez-en c'est souvent des femmes qui
sont responsabilités comme vous l'êtes
et ailleurs dans les entreprises tout ça
qui travaillent beaucoup et Madame
Lambert l'a bien expliqué dans son
parcours qui s'investissent énormément
et qui sont toujours très compétents
voilà maintenant que j'en reviens à la
séquence qui m'intéresse qui est
consacrée donc à la genèse des
territoires ruraux et la jeunesse c'est
la vie nous qui sommes attachés à notre
territoire européen n'est pas très jeune
ça c'est sûr mais on sait que c'est
surtout le devenir de nos territoire
nous donne nos territoires
donc à cette jeunesse dans les
territoires ruraux aux opportunités qui
sortent à elle et qui constituaient un
axe central de notre rapport
d'informations
de la délégation plutôt qui se sont
investis dans ce rapport parce que ça
vraiment mis en lumière la problématique
et toutes les problématiques que nous
vivons au quotidien que nous connaissons
donc nous l'avons montré dans notre
rapport les jeunes filles des
territoires ruraux font face à des
souhaits et injonctions contradictoires
il s'agit souvent pour elle de faire un
choix est-ce qu'elle parte pour avoir
plus d'autonomes d'opportunités dans
tous les domaines ou bien ce qu'elle
reste pour souvent soutenir leur famille
et leur territoire les jeunes filles qui
de plus souvent le territoire que les
garçons pour poursuivre des études ou
trouver un premier emploi certaines
jeunes filles n'y reviennent souvent pas
une fois diplômée pourquoi parce qu'elle
ne trouve pas sur leur territoire des
métiers qui correspondent à la
qualification à la formation qu'elles
ont reçues les jeunes filles qui restent
en zone rurale ont un champ
d'opportunités plus limité que le reste
de leur classe d'âge et surtout que les
jeunes filles qui sont
issus des villes dans tous les domaines
elle poursuivent moins d'études seul 52%
des étudiantes vivant en zone rurale
vise au moins un bac + 4 ou 5 contre 65%
des étudiantes urbaines
elles occupent davantage d'emplois
précaires travail essentiellement dans
tout ce qu'on appelle le coeur
c'est-à-dire les secteurs du soin et de
l'aide à la personne elle pratique aussi
moins d'activités sportives
occupent les espaces intérieurs et sont
invisibilisés dans les discours publics
et sociaux nous avons souhaité faire un
focus sur le sujet de l'orientation
scolaire et universitaire car de
nombreux freins pèsent encore sur
l'orientation des jeunes filles parmi
lesquelles une offre de formation faible
et peu diversifiée en milieu rurale
conjugués avec des opportunités
professionnelles plus limitées un manque
d'accompagnement dans certains choix
d'orientation des difficultés à quitter
le territoire un manque de confiance en
soi c'est comme ça aussi qu'elle réponde
de nom quand on les sollicite souvent
c'est vrai pour toutes les femmes en
général un manque de confiance en
l'avenir l'absence de référence au rôle
modèle féminin ou encore des stéréotypes
de genre non c'est pas du ressort des
femmes vous en avez parlé aussi pas mal
quand vous avez cité les
vice-présidents au sein des intercos et
oui on va à la genèse et oui on va la
petite enfance et oui sociale mais on
peut s'occuper de finances et de route
face à cela nous avons formulé cinq
recommandations vous savez que quand on
fait un rapport on fait un état des
lieux Annick en a parlé notamment nous
avons travaillé 10 mois au Sénat et sur
nos territoires et puis nous nous
faisons des recommandations des
propositions qu'après nous essayons
d'insérer comme le président l'archet
l'a dit soit au sein des débats que nous
avons au Sénat soit on peut reprendre
des recommandations pour les mettre dans
des textes de loi donc nous avons choisi
aujourd'hui de vous présenter cinq de
nos recommandations pour élargir le
champ des possibles des jeunes filles à
la fois au sein des territoires R uraux
et en dehors de ces territoires donc
première recommandation que je vous
présente nous souhaitons mener des
campagnes d'information à l'orientation
incarnée et inversant les stéréotypes en
utilisant des figures et des rôles
modèles féminins pour recruter au sein
des filières perçues comme masculine et
vice-versa
cela doit aller de pair avec une
éducation et une sensibilisation à
l'égalité des élèves filles comme
garçons mais aussi des enseignants et
des conseillers d'orientation
nous souhaitons aussi encourager les
dispositifs de mentorat et les
partenariats entre les collèges et
lycées ruraux et associés des
associations et programmes type les
coordonnées de la réussite des
territoires aux grandes écoles ou encore
chemin d'avenir les associations font un
gros travail et nous aurons l'occasion
tout à l'heure je reviendrai
d'additionner quelqu'un dont je vais
vous parler tout de suite qui s'appelle
Salomé Berlio qui est fondatrice
justement de l'association chemin
d'avenir que nous avions auditionné déjà
au sein de
quand nous avons fait le rapport et qui
est présente parmi nous ce matin en
visio donc nous recommandons également
de développer les solutions permettant
aux jeunes de suivre un minima deux
années d'études supérieures à proximité
de leur domicile par exemple en ouvrant
de nouveaux BTS en ayant recours au
campus connecté ou en ouvrant des
antennes universitaires délocalisées le
départ du domicile à 20 ans est ensuite
plus
enfin nous pensons sincèrement
d'accompagner la mobilité des jeunes
filles comme l'a dit Annick tout à
l'heure en préambule et la mobilité et
la difficulté à se déplacer les
déplacements en territoire ruraux et le
sujet qui est intervenu dans toutes les
thématiques que nous avons que nous
avons étudié donc justement nous
espérions notamment visant à instaurer
des transports sécurisés le financement
de séjour or du territoire et
l'attribution
de bourse d'une manière plus générale je
suis convaincue que tout ce que nous
faisons pour amener la question de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
dans nos territoires ruraux et dévoiler
les stéréotypes de genre contribue à
ouvrir le champ des possibles pour les
jeunes femmes de nos territoires donc
nous allons échanger sur ce sujet avec
deux intervenantes que je remercie
vraiment qu'elles d'avoir accepté de
participer à nos débats
elles sont en visio donc compte tenu de
la situation un grand merci à elle donc
nous allons d'abord avoir la chance
d'écouter Salomé Berlio donc fondatrice
de l'association chemin d'avenir et puis
ensuite Laurence Perez maire de
saint-jean-de-galaure dans mon
département la Drôme elle est maire
d'une commune rurale de
1275 habitants alors je commence par me
tourner vers Salomé Berlio donc vous
aviez vous avez créé en 2016
l'association chemin d'avenir après
avoir fait un triple constat
premièrement les jeunes des territoires
ruraux sont très nombreux deuxièmement
ces jeunes rencontres un certain nombre
d'obstacles ou de défis dans la
construction de leur parcours et ces
obstacles portent atteinte à l'égalité
des chances entre les jeunes Français
enfin troisièmement ce thème est resté
très longtemps un angle mort des
politiques publiques et des dispositifs
d'égalité des chances et au sein de
cette jeunesse les filles font dans ce
contexte face à un triple déterminisme
géographique sociale et de genre je vous
laisse donc sans plus tarder la parole
afin que vous nous exposiez plus
précisément les verrous à l'oeuvre dans
le parcours des jeunes filles vivaient
en milieu rural ainsi que les solutions
pour les faire sauter je vous remercie
madame
merci beaucoup madame est-ce que vous
m'entendez bien tous et toutes
j'espère que je parle suffisamment fort
à manger déverrouillé mon ça va pas du
tout là non ça va pas
on vous entend très mal et il y a
beaucoup de grésillement
est-ce que c'est mieux ainsi
beaucoup
oui vraiment
couper la caméra
alors est-ce que c'est mieux maintenant
non pas mieux
alors on va pas donner la parole
peut-être à quelqu'un d'autre moi ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on donne la
parole à notre intervenante et que au
niveau de la technique il voit comment
ils peuvent faire éventuellement en fait
on fait comme ça en espérant que la
deuxième soit mieux
donc je vais donner la parole à Laurence
Perez mettre maire de
saint-jean-de-galorn donc qui va revenir
je n'en doute pas sur tout ce tout ce
qu'elle a pu mettre en place elle et
parfois de manière indirecte ou parfois
directe à l'échelle d'une commune rurale
pour faire avancer
l'égalité famome auprès des jeunes
la première des choses je dis parce que
je sais que Laurence est parfois modeste
donc pour en parler la première des
choses des choses c'est ce que je vous
ai dit on prend un bulle c'est l'exemple
Laurence grâce à la manière dont elle se
saisit de son rôle de mère dont elle
incarne au quotidien comme beaucoup
d'entre vous ici montrent jeunes filles
et aux jeunes femmes de sa commune que
oui nous sommes légitimes en tant que
femme à exercer des responsabilités et à
prétendre au plus haute fonction
politique et puis je crois qu'elle a un
bel exemple mais je lui en laisse la
primeur d'un post qu'elle occupe sur
lequel on attend pas du tout une femme à
toi Laurence
est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
en fait on vous entend très bien ah tu
peux
commencer
ok bonjour à vous donc je vais commencer
par me présenter effectivement donc je
m'appelle Laurence Perez je suis mère
depuis 2014 alors merci en tout cas
Marie-Pierre pour cette invitation je
suis mère depuis 2014 en réalité d'une
commune de 800 habitants en 2014 et
effectivement
1275 depuis 2020 depuis 2022 même
précisément parce que je viens en
l'occurrence aussi de créer une commune
nouvelle donc je salue particulièrement
Françoise Gatel
et tous les membres de
sénateurs et invité aujourd'hui mais
voilà j'avais une petite attention pour
qu'on fasse d'appel par rapport à ce
sujet effectivement ce que disait
Marie-Pierre aussi c'est que je suis
donc mer et je suis aussi présidente
d'un syndicat de collecte d'ordures
ménagères donc pareil référence à
Françoise tout à l'heure sur un
territoire de 72000 habitants donc
effectivement c'était pas un endroit où
on attend les femmes je suis président
de ce syndicat en ayant succédé à un
homme bien entendu dans avec un exécutif
où il y avait cinq vice-présidents
hommes on a réussi aujourd'hui dans
d'avoir une présidente et une
vice-présidente pour une femme et trois
vice-présidents hommes et cela
fonctionne très bien effectivement je le
rappelle aussi souvent on peut être
femme et savoir compter gérer un budget
de 10 millions d'euros en l'occurrence
et faire baisser la taxe d'ordures
ménagères ce qui est quand même est
aussi envieux et envié par par beaucoup
de d'élus en ce moment donc pour le
reste je voulais juste être intervenir
sur la discussion précédente sur les
quotas effectivement je trouve pas ce
mot très joli pour autant je voudrais
juste rappeler que on ne doit pas
souffrir du syndrome de l'imposteur et
que le premier postulat en disant oui
mais bon aller chercher des femmes alors
que on a déjà pas assez d'hommes dans
des petites communes
c'est un peu se tromper on n'est pas
plus soft que en ville et aller chercher
des femmes en réalité dans les communes
de moins de 1000 c'est aussi possible
que dans des plus grandes communes ont
aussi nombreuses Marie-Pierre le
rappeler on représente plus la moitié de
l'humanité donc autant en réalité que
que en ville et aller chercher des
femmes c'est faisable aller chercher des
femmes compétentes c'est tout autant
faisable et se dire que remplir un
conseil municipal homme
du coup on a déjà du mal à faire des
listes alors pourquoi aller chercher les
femmes moi je dirais pourquoi aller
chercher des hommes donc est-ce que la
solution c'est réduire le nombre de
conseils municipaux je ne sais pas en
tout cas moi sur la liste que j'avais
faite en 2014 et en 2020 sur 15 conseils
municipaux j'ai toujours réussi à faire
la parité aujourd'hui sur ma communauté
je n'ai plus puisque on fait marrer avec
une commune dans laquelle il n'y avait
pas la parité puisque le maire était un
homme aussi mais je lui en veux pas du
tout on travaille aujourd'hui
dans la main en parfum
le prochain conseil aura aussi de toute
façon un conseil paritaire et de qualité
et de compétences
concernant donc le sujet d'aujourd'hui
sur
les jeunes et la jeunesse en ruralité
effectivement sur une petite commune je
vais pas vous donner des tonnes
d'exemples sur ce que j'ai pu faire pour
faire avancer ce sujet parce que sur une
petite commune bien entendu que la
difficulté c'est aussi le budget et que
des politiques publiques seront
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre à
l'échelle d'une petite commune pour
autant je crois effectivement en
l'exemplarité comme le disait
Marie-Pierre et l'exemplarité ça passe
déjà en étant une femme mère en souvant
effectivement à cette jeunesse et en
montrant que c'est possible c'est
possible d'être femme merde c'est aussi
possible d'être entrepreneur c'est aussi
possible d'être maman enfin tout est
possible
donc au quotidien comment ça s'articule
tout d'abord on a souhaité créer des
2014 un groupe de jeunes parce que on
avait aussi sa difficulté à ruralité qui
l'école on a des écoles publiques mais
on a aussi beaucoup d'écoles privées et
donc des enfants qui ne se fréquentent
pas forcément et nous on voulait les
rassembler donc on a fait un appel à la
jeunesse on leur disant ben si vous avez
envie de faire quelque chose venez nous
voir et on a eu beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont venus donc on a un groupe de jeunes
qui s'est qui s'est créé
ils sont en Junior Association et donc
ça fait 8 ans que ça dure et donc elle
est jeune ont évolué depuis 8 ans et
Candice mais leur leur frère leur sœur
leur cousins leurs amis intègrent au fur
et à mesure le groupe ils ont entre 12
et 18 ans à peu près
et dans les discussions avec le ben
rapidement on évoque l'idée de la parité
de la gouvernance quand les doyen en
avoir une sur un binôme paritaire des
organisations de ce qui peuvent mettre
en place comme animation autour de
l'intergénération aussi c'est quelque
chose auquel on tient et donc on a des
échanges très riches à ce niveau-là
comment on peut intervenir au niveau de
ce groupe de jeunes mais aussi de tout
ce qu'on va mettre en place sur la
jeunesse sur notre commune à l'aide
d'une association qui s'appelle famille
rurale et des animations qu'on peut
mettre en place sur notre commune des
chantiers loisirs etc
ça tient essentiellement aux activités
qu'on va proposer moi je fais en sorte
très rapidement de dire que je ne veux
pas d'activité genre ou trop j'en rêve
enfin voilà c'est à dire que dans les
activités il y aura pas forcément
proposé de foot
et que on va essayer de trouver des
activités dans lesquelles s'épanouir
mais ensemble voilà on va essayer de pas
avoir d'activités
rapidement la remarque oui mais moi ma
petite fille c'est une fille elle aime
bien jouer au foot oui ok pas de souci
elle aime bien jouer au foot mais après
s'il y avait un garçon qui voulait faire
de la danse il serait moins
épanoui parce qu'on va pas lui proposer
ça ou qu'on va stigmatiser donc le nom
genre c'est aussi ça s'est proposé des
activités plus autour de la nature d'un
quotidien qui est encore une fois n'est
pas juste genre en tant que tel
comment on va proposer aussi
de l'exemplarité sur ma commune par
exemple ça en route pour à l'importance
du patrimoine comme dans beaucoup
d'endroits de France on n'a pas de nom
de rue de nom de bâtiments dédié à des
femmes qui pourraient donc laisser le
champ des possibles à un moment donné où
la représentation a des jeunes femmes et
donc pour exemple le bâtiment qu'on est
en train de construire qui serait un
bâtiment culturel avec une salle des
associations une bibliothèque à l'étage
un espace public etc il va s'appeler
donc blanche perron il a été décidé à
l'unanimité du conseil municipal qui
était une officière de l'Armée du Salut
et qui a la fondatrice entre autres du
palais de la femme un hôtel social à
Paris
et donc voilà j'entrais pas dans le
détail mais c'est aussi cette idée là de
donner des noms de femmes à des lieux
et surtout de encore une fois tout le
temps offrir le champ des possibles
voilà c'est important que les jeunes
filles en réalité comme ailleurs
puissent se dire que elle peuvent le
faire et quand je dis elles peuvent le
faire je veux pas juste dire des métiers
très prestigieux comme on pourrait
l'entendre en réalité ce qui peut être
compliqué pour des jeunes aussi et j'ai
le cas donc autant que ça ne dit pas que
je préside
emménagères que sur ma commune il y a
aussi des métiers quels ont le droit de
faire comme chauffeur pour le haut elles
ont le droit de de faire ça elles ont le
droit d'être bouchées j'ai le cas d'une
jeune fille sur ma commune qui est
bouchée qui souffre aussi régulièrement
de de misogynie mais pour autant voilà
comme moi elle m'en parle elle est venue
m'en parler je me dis waouh vas-y
et donc ça va dans encore une fois dans
tout ce champ des possibles
et puis enfin
comment on peut faire cet exemplarité et
cette possibilité qu'on offre jeunes
filles c'est dans la déconstruction d'un
monde
assez masculin au quotidien ou la femme
a une place au second plan et là pour le
coup encore plus on va en réalité je
donnerai juste un exemple quand on
échange par exemple dans des conditions
cantines avec nos agents et les élus et
des parents sur le fonctionnement
l'amélioration de ce fonctionnement etc
on a eu le cas de dire mais voilà les
enfants aident à mettre la table les
enfants aident à débarrasser la table ce
qui est génial et puis quand nous serons
pousse un peu et qu'on pose la question
de dire bon ben ok mais qui débarrasse
la table est-ce que c'est des filles ou
des garçons ou est-ce que c'est mélangé
et ben
99 fois sur 100 la réponse c'est non
c'est que des jeunes filles non mais
elles en ont envie c'est elle qui
demande et ouais pendant ce temps-là les
garçons vont jouer au foot donc ça c'est
pas ce qu'on souhaite pour demain c'est
pas ce qu'on souhaite en ruralité pour
que effectivement ces jeunes filles
sachent qu'elles ont le droit aussi d'un
défaut foot si elles veulent mais
d'aller lire un livre de joie des jeux
de société de faire plein d'autres
choses que les garçons ont le droit
aussi et doivent aussi participer au
quotidien un débarrasser la table et pas
juste regarder des films et construire
continuer à construire ce schéma ou ils
le font pas méchamment bien entendu mais
c'est juste normal pour eux d'aller
jouer et que les filles débarrassent et
c'est juste normal pour elle aussi donc
voilà on essaye de construire tout ça au
quotidien sur encore une fois du
vocabulaire aussi qu'on va utiliser sur
des expositions qu'on va créer ou ou
louer et mettre en place dans ma petite
commune donc j'ai pu bénéficier de
l'exposition
des élus contre les violences faites aux
femmes qui a eu un vif succès qu'on a
ouvert à des heures
de dimanche du marché par exemple pour
que il y ait pas uniquement les gens
sensibles à cette cause qui viennent
franchir le pas de la porte et accéder à
cette à cette exposition donc voilà il y
a pas comme je vous disais des grosses
politiques publiques parce qu'on n'a pas
assez de moyens mais en tout cas on
essaye au quotidien de d'offrir et
d'ouvrir aux filles en ruralité le champ
des possibles sur la carrière le métier
la vie qu'elles auraient envie de faire
et pas rester sur des stéréotypes de
gens ou le modèle patriarcal ancien qui
qui quand même perdure voilà je vous
remercie et puis je suis prête à
répondre à vos questions si vous en avez
merci merci Laurence alors d'abord
est-ce qu'on peut se connecter ou pas
avec notre autre intervenant de pas pour
le moment donc je vous propose
d'échanger je vais juste compléter un
petit peu ce qui a été dit
dans le rapport nous allons noter que
pour inviter les filles au départ
c'était compliqué par rapport au système
scolaire comme pour leur part d'ailleurs
parce que les établissements d'études je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure sont peu
nombreux sur nos territoires et nous
avions parlé aussi de la situation dans
les outre-mer il y a une collègue qui
est notre mère je crois ou l'injonction
au départ est encore plus forte
peut-être qu'en métropole parce que la
distance est encore plus loin voilà si
elle souhaite intervenir et parler un
petit peu de son territoire ce sera avec
plaisir parce que nous souhaitons
toujours au Sénat de préoccuper de la
situation dans les autres mères
merci madame la Présidente
merci Marie-Pierre et c'est toujours un
plaisir de participer à l'application au
doigt des femmes je rejoins énormément
tout ce que j'ai entendu depuis ce matin
effectivement les retrouve dans ces
petits territoires qui sont isolés mais
qui ont tendance à s'émanciper je suis
pour avoir été enseignante et directrice
d'école pendant nombreuses années il
était vraiment très très important au
niveau déjà dès le niveau scolaire de
diversifier et de montrer aux garçons
qui avaient pas
des fonctions pour les garçons et des
fonctions pour les filles mais que
vraiment tout le monde était alors chez
nous les filles font du foot
les gars s'en font de la danse enfin il
y a pas il y a ce respect mutuel et on
essaie de sortir de ces clichés mais il
y a quelques années et il est vrai que
comme les jeunes n'avaient pas les
moyens de pouvoir partir puisqu'il n'y a
pas de lycée à Saint-Barthélémy il y a
qu'un collège donc il fallait pouvoir
poursuivre dans la vie active on avait
créé donc un centre bâtiment pour les
garçons et les filles étaient réservées
au travaux ménagères crochet enfin bref
il y avait vraiment cette séparation ou
la femme était là pour tenir le foyer et
le mari pour travailler à porter donc
les choses ont vraiment beaucoup évolué
mais malgré tout l'isolement et prégnant
donc je vais laisser la parole si elle
le souhaite à ma première
vice-présidente madame Marie-Hélène
Bernier qui a beaucoup œuvré aussi dans
le sang pour l'environnement à la base
et qui travaille
au niveau du social et à toutes ces
problématiques voilà
alors déjà merci je suis assez ému
d'être là j'ai écouté madame Lambert
tout à l'heure ça m'a beaucoup touchée
son discours parce que c'est vrai que
dans ce genre de réunion en tout cas
pour moi c'est souvent des des discours
très techniques ou très global et parler
de soi c'est quelque chose qui nous
touche tous parce qu'on est tous des
femmes
ceux qui sont femmes ici en tout cas
je pense que ce genre de discours
personnel touche parce
qu'on est tous un petit peu concerné moi
je suis un petit peu moins optimiste que
Micheline c'est vrai que les choses ont
avancées dans l'égalité homme-femme moi
je dis qu'il y a encore énormément
de travail à faire pour que les femmes
puissent être
[Musique]
ce qu'elle devrait être en fait
considéré pour ce qu'elles sont leurs
compétences ou juste leur leur
position de femmes voilà donc il y a
encore énormément de travail à faire
donc pour me présenter vite fait donc je
suis la première vice-présidente depuis
un an à la collectivité de
Saint-Barthélemy
je me suis présentée la première fois
parce que je viens du milieu associatif
donc j'ai présidé fondé une association
en 2009 pour la préservation du
patrimoine local de l'environnement
j'ai jusqu'à cette année puisque je suis
devenue première vice-présidente enfin
2022 et
j'ai été la seule femme à
Saint-Barthélemy amené une liste aux
élections en 2017
sinon c'était toujours des hommes qui
qui étaient tête de liste donc c'était
difficile quand même en tant que femme
parce que en 2017 on m'a quand même dit
tu es une femme tu es homosexuelle il
manquait plus le statut d'être une femme
noire pour combler
les
donc voilà les caricatures merci donc
voilà
il faut lutter en tout cas pour ce qu'on
est avec nos convictions et
les femmes sont une force exceptionnelle
je trouve donc merci encore pour
l'invitation merci à Micheline aussi et
je suis contente d'être là très heureuse
d'être là merci pour ce témoignage fort
oui c'est important de le dire et
d'assumer et qu'on se libère aussi
globalement et qu'on mette pas parce que
souvent ça c'était ce qui m'avait c'est
quand je suis à la délégation on a fait
une table ronde et on m'a demandé de
m'interroger sur ma carrière je me suis
rendu compte qu'on se mettait nous-mêmes
vous voyez les barrières et il faut
arriver à se libérer de ça
si vous avez donc des questions à poser
à Laurence ne gênait pas aussi vous avez
aussi envie de nous faire partager votre
votre expérience ou ce que vous pouvez
faire sur vos communes allez-y est-ce
que quelqu'un souhaite prendre
oui je vous en prie
donc moi je suis Madame serin je suis
mère d'un village de 200 habitants
première femme mère dans mon village et
juste pour un petit témoignage en fait
donc je suis mère maire et mère et j'ai
eu mon deuxième enfant en fait en 2021
donc même pas un an après avoir été élu
au poste de mer au sein du conseil
municipal j'ai eu les félicitations que
ce soit les hommes comme les femmes mais
plutôt au niveau de l'intercommunalité
faut savoir que un milieu rural
intercommunalité c'est majoritairement
des hommes j'ai pas forcément le ratio
mais je pourrais dire au moins 80%
d'hommes
des hommes retraités ou en fait il y a
une incompréhension totale pour eux le
fait d'avoir eu un deuxième enfant
c'était comme si j'avais un peu
abandonné mes fonctions donc on m'a
reproché quand même mon absence durant
mon congé maternité même si une semaine
après avoir accouché étant rentré à la
maison j'ai repris mes fonctions de mer
et je tiens à préciser que je suis
entièrement épanouie dans ma vie
personnelle dans ma vie d'élus et
également dans ma vie professionnelle
parce que en plus j'ai aussi une
activité professionnelle donc voilà je
pense que les mentalités évoluent
au niveau du village c'est souvent salué
qu'une femme jeune et en vie et là je
reviens je rejoins un peu sur ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure c'est pas une
question d'homme aux femmes mais plutôt
une question de compétence et aussi
d'envie et je trouve ça positif qu'on
s'arrête pas justement à la question de
genre en se disant c'est un homme c'est
une femme peu importe au final c'est
avoir l'envie et les convictions de le
faire mais justement au niveau de
certains élus à l'heure actuelle il y a
des choses qui qui sont pour moi une
hérésie de des propos qui ne devraient
même pas être tenues donc voilà c'était
juste pour faire un témoignage voilà sur
on peut avoir des épanouissements
professionnels et personnelles qui se
rejoignent et qui ne sont pas
contradictoires donc voilà je vous
remercie tout à fait la seule instance
dans nos différentes instances qui est
vraiment paritaires c'est les ce sont
les conseils départementaux présidence
des départements c'est seulement comme
les maires 20% de femmes et président
des interco c'est à peu près 20% c'est
pareil et je vous rejoins sur les
intercommunalités qui sont rurales on
touche à cette il faut que les femmes
soient mère parce que souvent pour des
équilibres on met au sein de l'exécutif
des interco les mers des communes qui
sont majoritairement des femmes donc se
posent la question de des listes enfin
comment vont être constitués les listes
pour les communes en dessous de 1000
Jean-Michel évoquet on a beaucoup
réfléchi même si ça fait pas l'unanimité
et c'est vrai que la mes rêves se pince
aussi là-dessus on avait même réfléchi
un binôme éventuellement voyez parce que
pour qu'on soit plus présente voilà mais
c'est vrai que c'est majoritairement des
dans les territoires ruraux des hommes
qui sont dans les exécutifs des interco
je crois qu'il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui
souhaitait parler
[Musique]
que je fasse que je tape sur la table
pour me faire voir donc je le fais je le
fais pas je le fais dans il commence à
annoncer la liste il propose sa liste et
puis d'un seul coup je me lève je l'ai
écouté je voudrais prendre la parole il
me laisse la parole et je dis voilà j'ai
demandé j'ai proposé ma candidature à
Monsieur et il l'a refusé et un autre
monsieur se lève et dis-moi aussi il me
l'a refusé un autre se lève il dit moi
aussi et donc un autre monsieur dit on
n'est pas en Russie si on veut se
présenter on se présente je me suis
présenté j'ai eu le plus de voix j'ai
été élu mais je peux vous dire qu'après
ça pas été difficile il y a pas très
longtemps j'ai demandé des des
renseignements concernant un dossier on
met des tuts tu te taire ou alors je
t'enlève tes indemnités
alors là je lui dis et bah vas-y je suis
prête c'est le moment donc voilà et j'en
passe et d'autres par exemple quand des
fois j'arrive une faible tu as vu
comment que tu es habillée bah je sais
que je suis bien habillée et une fois on
a eu la présence d'un préfet et il fait
au préfet tu as vu elle est maintenant
c'est une blonde qui va devenir grise
donc
[Musique]
c'est des propos mais je donc
là le monsieur le Préfet dit et Monsieur
le Préfet intervient en disant écoutez
madame monsieur elle fait comme elle
veut je n'interviendrai pas donc voilà
c'était une parenthèse que je
c'est c'était une
mais c'est pas il y a pas que lui il y a
pas que lui mais c'était une parenthèse
mais pour dire que quand j'écoute qu'on
s'écoute tout je pense que la femme a
vraiment besoin qu'on la mette en valeur
elle a besoin d'outils surtout de
d'outils et de formation moi je sais que
je suis devenue mère aussi par hasard
comme la dame qui intervenu tout à
l'heure je me suis vraiment reconnue
là-dedans
parce que c'est vrai que quand on est
une femme dans un milieu oral moi c'est
pareil j'étais la première femme dans
mon village je peux vous dire que j'en
ai pris cher j'ai de nombreuses fois
pleurer en arrêt j'ai jamais pleuré
devant les personnes mais arrivé chez
moi je pleurais voilà et je pense qu'on
n'est pas assez soutenu de ce côté là on
n'a pas assez de on a
il nous faut des éléments les éléments
de langage les éléments intervenir parce
que moi je me souviens aussi je fais
dans avec l'association on met en place
des ateliers autodéfense pour le
dialogue le dialogue riposter enfin ça
nous a énormément servi avec un
psychologue parce que on n'est pas formé
mais il n'y a pas que les femmes il y a
les hommes aussi parfois sont pas formés
savent pas comment réagir mais je pense
qu'on a vraiment un manque de de
formation parce qu'on arrive mais on est
maire on est là on l'a voulu on l'a
choisi moi j'ai voulu bon ma j'ai pas je
suis arrivé mère
je n'y connaissais rien du tout et donc
c'est ça aussi je voulais intervenir on
vous dites les compétences les
compétences les compétences mais non il
y a beaucoup de femmes qui aimeraient
s'investir mais comme on dit toujours
compétences elles ont peur de pas y
arriver moi je vous assure je suis dans
le syndicat d'eau je n'y connaissais
rien mais mais j'ai pu considère enfin
je connaissais des choses que certains
de mes collègues mer qui étaient
vice-présidents
le menu dès que j'ai été lu mon posait
plein de questions yes je savais
répondre mais eux je leur ai posé les
questions il savait pas donc c'est pour
ça il faut pas il faut pas il faut il
faut certes avoir des compétences mais
même si on en a pas il faut donner
confiance il faut se donner confiance et
après par contre après avoir des outils
pour savoir pouvoir avancer par exemple
prendre la parole moi c'est un truc qui
m'est très dur
en public non mais là parce que non mais
parce que là on est entre femmes et
quelques hommes non mais c'est je vous
assure parce que quand vous êtes devant
plein d'hommes vous savez que vous êtes
jugé et là c'est différent là c'est
différent moi je vois dans l'heure au
niveau du département au niveau du
département je sais que je vais
bafouiller et là je vais en prendre
plein enfin c'est parce que je sais que
je suis jugé et ça il faut vraiment pour
les femmes je pense qu'on est vraiment
un besoin de de d'outils enfin mais pas
que pour les femmes il y a des hommes
qui sont pareils bien sûr donc voilà moi
je vais
arrêter là merci beaucoup
c'était très intéressant votre et je
pense c'est la réalité de beaucoup et si
vous discutez avec vos femmes élues vous
avez fait une mère femme mère vous savez
combien parfois c'est difficile et le
regard que les autres portent sur nous
et qu'on a donc fournir un effort
supplémentaire mais on est capable alors
je crois que Madame Salomé Berlio est là
on va essayer ça devrait fonctionner à
vous madame Berlio oui on a décidé de
tenter une deuxième fois est-ce que
c'est mieux ou pas du tout oui oui c'est
bien c'est mieux
ok bon je vous prie de m'excuser j'avais
pourtant testé les choses en amont mais
je vais essayer d'être encore plus
rapide que prévu pour ne pas vous
imposer un son approximatif de toute
façon vous avez déjà en introduction
dit beaucoup de choses et puis surtout
tout ce qui a été dit depuis tout à
l'heure et à la fois passionnant et
abondent très largement dans le sens des
travaux que je mène depuis 2016 travaux
de terrain via l'association chemin
d'avenir donc vous avez parlé les
travaux plus de recherche à travers
différents livres notamment les
invisibles de la République qui met en
lumière la vie et les défis des jeunes
dans la ruralité et les petites communes
de France et puis un certain nombre de
rapports que j'ai eu l'opportunité de
rendre oppressée dans le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et dont certaines
des recommandations destinées aux jeunes
des honoraires et des petites villes
sont aujourd'hui l'objet
d'expérimentation de politique publique
vous l'avez dit un introduction est très
bien dit on a parfois tendance à penser
que les jeunes des Honor rurales et des
petites villes sont une poignée de
filles et de fils d'agriculteurs
évidemment vous qui connaissez un petit
nom c'était territoire vous savez bien
que c'est loin d'être le cas 23 % des
moins de 20 ans donc dans les zones
rurales si on ajoute les jeunes des
petites villes on est très vite à plus
de 60% des jeunes français donc c'est
loin d'être un phénomène à la marge
d'autre part ces jeunes et j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir qui me fasse à
une série d'obstacles vous l'avez dit et
effectivement en 2016 quand j'ai frappé
aux portes des ministères ou des
entreprises pour essayer d'attirer
l'attention sur la diversité
territoriale et sur la nécessité d'aller
chercher les jeunes de la ruralité pour
les mettre en lumière pour raconter leur
parcours et pour leur donner accès à des
opportunités en plus je vais pas dire
qu'on me rayonnait mais la réalité c'est
que ça bougeait peu à ce moment-là
depuis les lignes lentement mais
sûrement et on voit qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire mais j'y
reviendrai aussi effectivement triple
déterminisme pour les jeunes des zones
rurales alors il faut tout de suite
nuancer les choses évidemment la réalité
pour ces jeunes filles est très
différente selon leur famille la
situation de professionnelle de leurs
parents et même selon leur territoire
même parce que cela sans doute été déjà
dit au préalable ce matin mais il y a
plusieurs types de ruralité et donc
évidemment de la même façon il y a
plusieurs situations très nuancées très
différentes pour les jeunes femmes et
les jeunes filles dans ce territoire
mais parfois pour trouver des solutions
qui soient à la hauteur d'un problème
général il faut accepter de généraliser
un peu et de prendre une situation dans
son ensemble raison pour laquelle je me
permets d'affirmer que globalement les
jeunes filles des zones rurales comme
celles des petites communes ne sont pas
dans la même situation de départ face à
l'avenir que les jeunes filles qui
grandissent dans le coeur de Lyon de
Paris ou de Bordeaux quand on parle de
triple déterminisme je reviens très
brièvement sur cette affirmation
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 80% des
classes populaires qui vivent en dehors
des grandes métropoles et de leur
banlieue et on connaît les fragilités
économiques et sociales de certains
territoires ruraux donc chez chemin
d'avenir par exemple on accompagne très
largement de jeunes boursiers et de
jeunes boursières dans ces territoires
là et on sait et j'enfonce des pommes
ouvertes à quel point elle se la
situation
économique et sociale des familles
pèsent sur les choix notamment des
jeunes filles au moment des choix
d'orientation
géographique déterminisme géographiques
dire cela ce n'est évidemment absolument
pas faire un jour à la ruralité j'en
profite pour préciser que j'ai moi-même
grandi dans un territoire très rural
dans l'Allier je suis restée entre
l'Allier et la Nièvre jusqu'à mes 18 ans
mes parents sont toujours là-bas je suis
évidemment très attachée à ces
territoires et c'est justement pour
permettre aux jeunes ces territoires et
aux jeunes filles de ces territoires
être pleinement actrice de leur
territoire et plus largement de leur vie
que nous cherchons avec chemin d'avenir
à offrir des solutions qui justement
permettent de surmonter ce triple
déterminisme et quand on parle de
déterminisme géographique pensons au
nombre de jeunes filles qu'on a entendu
dire ce n'est pas fait pour moi parce
que je viens de la campagne de la même
manière d'ailleurs que beaucoup de
jeunes filles disent ce n'est pas fait
pour moi parce que je viens de banlieue
et ce pas fait pour moi il a quelque
chose d'insupportable à notre époque et
il est encore bien trop prégnant dans
les parcours de ces jeunes femmes et
donc un déterminisme de genre et bien à
nouveau tout ceci relève presque de la
la palissade mais c'est important de le
rappeler ici si une jeune femme a déjà
du mal à s'imaginer travailler dans la
tech être professeur de médecine
ingénieur ou pilote de chasse quand elle
grandit dans le coeur de Paris ou de
Lyon du fait d'une autocensure liée à
son genre on imagine très bien et vous
le savez encore une fois empiriquement
sur le terrain ce qu'il en est pour une
jeune fille qui grandit à La
Côte-Saint-André à Bourbon-l'Archambault
à Mirecourt dans des territoires de
montagne dans les territoires très
éloignés des grandes métropoles
mon intervention donc doit être
relativement courte aussi je ne pourrais
pas développer tous les aspects du
constat autour duquel l'équipe de chemin
d'avenir travaille depuis 7 ans
désormais avec la septième promotion de
jeunes lancés hier par l'association et
5000 jeunes accompagnés individuellement
dans la construction de leur parcours à
la fois académique professionnelle et
citoyen depuis 2016 j'en profite pour
dire que parmi nos bénéficiaires cette
jeune sur 10 sont des jeunes filles ce
qui n'est pas neutre parce que comme
nous les interrogeons et comme nous les
invitons à nous rejoindre sur le critère
de la motivation ça veut dire que la
motivation des jeunes filles dans ces
territoires là est grande mais ce qui
peut donner des situations d'autant plus
cruelle et je pèse les mots mais cruels
en tout cas douloureuse le mot est fort
mais réel quand on a des jeunes filles
qui sont motivés et qui n'arrivent pas à
réaliser pleinement leur potentiel donc
notre état dans tous les détails de ces
constats de la même manière que je
n'entrerai pas dans les détails les
différentes recommandations y d'ailleurs
parce que j'en ai entendu certaines tout
à l'heure qui me paraissait
particulièrement
pertinente et qui je le sais et je vous
en remercie s'inspirait aussi très
largement de nos travaux je concentrerai
donc mon propos autour de deux idées
d'une part l'accumulation d'obstacles
auquel font face les jeunes filles des
honoraires et d'autres parts la
nécessité de développer une approche
systémique dans les réponses à apporter
à cette situation
premier point donc très brièvement
l'accumulation des défis qui pèse sur le
présent et l'avenir de ces jeunes filles
on est dans une situation de chaîne
d'obstacles c'est vraiment ça où chaque
défi nourrit l'autre et rend parfois
tout simplement impossible la
réalisation du potentiel de ces jeunes
filles je vous cite certains des
obstacles mais vous les avez aussi
évoqués tout à l'heure le manque
d'informations concernant les filières
et les métiers qui existent et même
chose j'imagine que vous avez très
souvent entendu dire mais si j'avais su
si j'avais su que telle finir quand elle
métier existait évidemment que c'est ce
que j'aurais choisi puisque ça me
correspondait pleinement mais juste je
ne savais pas donc un déficit
d'information et des billets
d'information
l'autocensure typiquement féminine les
renforcer dans ses territoires c'est pas
fait pour moi parce que je donne la
ruralité c'est pas fait pour moi parce
que je suis une fille c'est pas fait
pour moi parce que je suis d'origine
modeste le manque de rôle modèle et ça
on avait fait un travail très
approfondie avec Jérôme Fourquet que
vous connaissez sans doute dans le cadre
de travaux avec la Fondation Jean Jaurès
montrant que réellement l'absence de
rôle modèle d'incarnation de modèles de
réussite et par réussite j'entends
réussisse au sens vraiment très très
large c'est pas uniquement aller dans
une grande école ou devenir chef
d'entreprise ou faire de la politique
c'est réussite au sens de je me sens
pleinement épanouie dans tout ce que
vous avez cité précédemment ma vie
personnelle ma vie professionnelle
j'arrive à articuler tout cela et bien
des modèles
qui se revendique comme venant de la
ruralité et qui sont à même de
représenter des parcours de réussite
plurielle pour ces jeunes femmes on en
manque ou en tout cas elle n'ose pas
toujours prendre la parole sur cette
thématique là et c'est là où d'ailleurs
on voit bien le retard que ce sujet là a
et que ces territoires ont dans la prise
de conscience de ses défis par rapport à
d'autres territoires à très fort défis
comme par exemple les banlieues où vous
avez de plus en plus des modèles de
réussite qui viennent dire j'ai grandi
dans un quartier très difficile je suis
très attachée à ce territoire j'en suis
partie pour telle et telle raison j'y
reviens pour telle et telle raison et je
suis chef cuistot je suis acteur ou
actrice je suis footballeur où j'ai
monté ma boîte dans la ruralité c'est
plus long et je pense que j'ai quelques
éléments de réponse sur pourquoi on
pourra y revenir ensuite si vous le
souhaitez mais en tout cas ce manque de
rôle modèle le la fraction numérique
également qui pèse mal avant tout sur
ces territoires là et très souvent dans
les grandes métropoles on va nous dire
mais aujourd'hui avec Internet
c'est facile de se connecter partout en
France et c'est facile de s'orienter or
on sait très bien que bien sûr il y a
des défis techniques liés à la fracture
digitale mais que ce sont aussi des
difficultés d'usage et que ça ne suffit
pas d'avoir internet pour s'orienter
qu'il faut être accompagné et bien
accompagné par sa famille pour pouvoir
le faire donc à nouveau ça dépend de
code que l'on n'a pas toujours dans la
ruralité le manque d'opportunités
académiques culturel professionnel à
proximité immédiate du domicile de ces
jeunes et donc la lourdeur ne serait-ce
que d'un point de vue financier quand il
faut partir même si on ne souhaite pas
toujours partir mais parfois il faut le
faire pour pouvoir se former voilà ça
t'accumulation d'obstacles qui fait que
si tout à coup l'information concernant
une filière ou un métier parvient à
temps à cette jeune fille d'un
territoire très rural mais qu'elle saute
aux censure qu'elle ne se sent pas
mobile qu'elle n'a pas les moyens
psychologiques ou matériel d'aller
étudier ailleurs que dans la vie à côté
de chez et bien la situation restera
très complexe et ce d'autant plus que et
vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure le
géographe Benoît Coquard par exemple
rappelait dans son excellente ouvrage ce
qui reste que les jeunes filles des
zones rurales ont une bonne réussite à
l'école avec globalement des résultats
qui sont même dans un premier temps
supérieur à la moyenne nationale même si
ça a tendance est à nuancer à mesure que
les jeunes filles avancent dans leur
parcours scolaire mais en tout cas par
rapport aux garçons du même territoire
ce sont elles qui sortent du lot en
termes de résultats scolaire de
motivation voire de volonté d'aller se
former et pour autant et pour autant
elle reste très largement déterminée
dans leur orientation et notamment
professionnelle voilà donc cet
accumulation d'obstacles on pourra y
revenir si vous le souhaitez mais il
faut en prendre la pleine mesure pour
pouvoir ensuite déjouer chacun de ces
freins qui limitent le parcours de ces
jeunes filles et ceci m'emmène à mon
deuxième et dernier point qui dit chaîne
d'obstacles dit chaîne de solution
ou pour le dire autrement et je pense
que vraiment cette matinée témoigne du
fait que la situation elle est en train
de bouger et je pense qu'on enfin ça
mérite d'être vraiment dit et vraiment
saluer mais la situation des jeunes
filles des zones rurales et des petites
communes de France à ce jour demande une
réaction collective et massive pour
retourner une tendance inscrite dans le
temps et non prise en compte pendant des
décennies on est là face à un sujet qui
est profondément déplorable à l'échelle
individuelle autant de destins de jeunes
filles de jeunes femmes qui ne se
réalisent pas autant de jeunes filles ou
de jeunes femmes qui auront l'impression
de ne pas être allé au bout de leur
potentiel que ce soit reprendre la
flamme de leurs parents dans de bonnes
conditions que ce soit devenir artisan
sur leur territoire dans de bonnes
conditions que ce soit avoir envie de
faire Sciences Po ou le ns sociales le
souhaitent et à l'échelle collective
pour dépasser l'échelle individuelle
c'est catastrophique sur les plans
économiques sociaux et
or pour être à la hauteur de l'enjeu il
faut j'en suis convaincu s'attaquer à la
racine du problème c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire et c'est ce qu'on
identifie avec chemin d'avenir c'est à
dire que je vous donne un exemple
comprendre aujourd'hui depuis 2016 nous
avons accompagné individuellement 5000
jeunes notre objectif quantitatif est
dans la barre accompagné
individuellement 25000 en 2025 mais on
est entre 3 et 4 millions des moins de
20 ans qui grandissent dans les zones
rurales donc autant vous dire que ce
qu'on fait c'est vraiment une miette de
pain et ça n'est absolument pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu donc il y a vraiment
une nécessité de faire bouger la société
française sur cette thématique des
jeunes des zones rurales et notamment
des jeunes filles d'influer sur les
mentalités du pays de provoquer une
prise de conscience les jeunes et
notamment les jeunes filles de ces
territoires ne sont pas en mesure
d'aller aussi loin qu'il est elles
peuvent aller la diversité territoriale
doit être mieux prise en compte
interrogeons-nous sur si on entend
beaucoup parler de divers territoriale
personnellement jamais et pourtant je
suis très attentive à ce sujet ou que ce
soit en entreprise on parle un peu plus
d'égalité fameux et de diversité on
parle de diversité d'origine diversité
territoriale il faut vraiment y aller à
la massue pour que les portes s'ouvrent
sur cette thématique là donc il faut des
dispositifs robustes dédiés à ces jeunes
les politiques publiques des politiques
d'entreprise il faut que les médias
s'emparent du sujet et ça ça a beaucoup
bougé depuis 2016 c'était très compliqué
d'avoir un article sur les jeunes ruraux
en 2016 aujourd'hui chez chemin d'avenir
nous sommes contactés toutes les
semaines pour avoir des articles pour
faire des reportages des documentsaires
sur ces gens-là il faut que la société
civile qui est très puissante dans ses
réponses intègrent cette notion de
ruralité et de jeunes filles des zones
rurales dans les réponses qu'elle
apporte que le grand public participe de
ce mouvement
et donc s'il y a des questions et je
m'en arrêterai là soit les dispositifs
que nous mettons en place chez le chemin
d'avenir et que nous préconisons à
l'échelle nationale sur les propositions
que nous avons faites j'y répondrai
volontiers mais pour cette intervention
c'était essentiellement les messages que
je voulais t'adresser à une audience qui
je le sais est particulièrement sensible
à ce sujet et agit déjà en sa faveur la
situation des jeunes filles des zones
rurales si on évite de la prendre au
sérieux comme vous le faites comme nous
le faisons chez chemin d'avenir elle
n'avancera pas et elle suppose au
contraire des réponses qui ne soient pas
homéopathiques mais la mobilisation de
toutes et de tous en commençant par une
prise de conscience collective et en
débouchant sur des actions concrètes je
vous remercie c'est nous qui vous
remercions d'abord pour votre
intervention comme celle de Laurence
tout à l'heure parce que c'est vous qui
est au plus près du terrain déjà et on
s'est en plus que le tissu associatif en
milieu rural est essentiel à notre vie
et à notre vivre ensemble donc déjà
grave pour ça et puis on a compris à
travers à vos propos que c'est un petit
peu le sens de notre rapport à la fois
quand vous avez parlé d'obstacles et de
solutions donc on est on peut dire tous
bien ensemble d'accord sur ce qu'il faut
faire alors il nous reste peu de temps
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même une
petite échange avec la salle essayer
d'être assez court si vous le permettez
dans vos interventions merci oui merci
merci ma belle présidente oui je l'ai
peut-être faire une petite conclusion
sur par rapport aux échanges qu'on a pu
avoir moi je viens dans effectivement un
territoire je viens de l'heure je
sénatrice de l'heure d'un territoire
extrêmement rural où moi j'ai 80% des
communes qui ont moins de 1000 habitants
donc effectivement on a des élus des
élus qui sont sur tous les fronts avec
vous voyez avec 80 pardon
on a des élus qui sont sur tous les
fronts parce qu'ils ont pas toute
l'ingénierie qu'on retrouve dans les
grosses communes et ce que je veux dire
un maire rural un maire de écouter il a
sa secrétaire de mairie si il a une
secrétaire de mairie parce que là
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé madame
il y a il y a une réelle pénurie de
secrétaire de mairie donc en France
et donc c'est c'est ta mère qui est à la
fois dans l'administratif qui est un
médiateur qui parfois se
est obligé aussi de mettre la main dans
tout ce qui est espace vert enfin vous
voyez desherbages voilà c'est le ménage
de l'église enfin voilà c'est voilà
c'est ça donc je voulais je voulais
vraiment saluer l'engagement de tous ces
élus des petites communes rurales
françaises qui représente je crois à peu
près je sais pas en chiffres on est à
peu près la moitié la moitié des
communes et oui un peu plus et
c'est là où je voulais je voulais dire
effectivement que ces élus là ont parlé
de formation aimerait effectivement
avoir plus facilement accès donc à la
formation en tout cas avoir des
formations renforcées et et puis je
pense qu'il y a un vrai sujet aussi sur
les secrétaires de mairie parce qu'il y
a il y a pas de formation à part entière
secrétaire de mairie donc on est obligé
de les mettre en binôme avec une
secrétaire par exemple qui part à la
retraite pendant 6 mois parce que
effectivement il y a il y a tout ce qui
est il y a des notions d'urbanisme
budget enfin à intégrer qui sont pas
évidentes parce qu'elles sont noyées
même si on parle de simplification on
les voit noyés dans un millefeuille
administratif qui est devenu
complètement hors norme voilà donc voilà
bravo à toutes ces élus des petites
communes rurales françaises voilà merci
Christina leur pelucher qui est
sénatrice de l'air c'est très bien votre
intervention parce que j'avais pensé
tout à l'heure j'ai oublié et en effet
c'est pas la même chose et en France
c'est plus de 50% des communes qui ont
moins de 500 habitants et 72% qui ont
moins de 1000 donc la France est très
rurale et ça tient le territoire et il y
a une PPL qui doit arriver début avril
c'est une proposition de loi qui vient
d'une de parlementaire et qui se
traitera du sujet des secrétaire de
mairie je peux que vous inviter à
regarder l'été
je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas si
c'est je sais pas si c'est pas Corinne
Brulet qui est active sur le sujet
Céline Brunet
merci qui d'autre souhaitent intervenir
oui alors moi je suis aussi maire d'une
petite commune bon et galère dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône
très jolie commune oui mais donc j'ai
une super secrétaire de mairie donc
voilà mais par contre oui juste après
madame la sénatrice on se base c'est
vrai sur tous les fronts pour beaucoup
de choses et je voudrais parler aussi
d'un problème qui concerne beaucoup les
femmes et moi je voudrais bien qu'on
m'aide à ce sujet parce que très
difficile de trouver des solutions c'est
par exemple l'aide en milieu rural pour
les gens qui sont dépendants ou qui en
ont besoin actuellement moi sur
Eygalières pour voir un petit village il
y a la DMR il y a à peu près 12
personnes qui travaillent et ce ne sont
que des femmes payées
Hollande Pierre et on est en train de
faire des appels pour trouver et
finalement il n'y a que des femmes que
des femmes qui travaillent mais qui ont
aussi des enfants donc qui ont les mêmes
problèmes que l'on disait tout à l'heure
après évidemment il y a une EHPAD mais
le prix de l'EHPAD qui est privé c'est
3000 euros par mois donc ça veut dire
que des gens qui sont en milieu rural et
qui sont à la retraite et qui ont entre
1000 et 1100 euros de retraite par mois
ne peuvent pas aller donc et pour
trouver ces services qui arrivent et qui
aident donc voilà je suis aujourd'hui au
Sénat pour les femmes et je dis bah
essayons de de s'entraider de se dire
bon qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer ses conditions de travail
parce que c'est vraiment un réel le
président l'archet a un petit peu abordé
alors aussi avec les violences faites
aux femmes mais franchement là c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très important
parce que le milieu rural on se trouve
démuni et on se dit mais comment on va
faire comment on va faire et quand vous
regardez les salaires ben on se dit oui
effectivement oui c'est normal qu'on ne
trouve que très peu de mais il en va de
notre de la vie et de la vie de
descente de de
nos citoyens enfin de tout le monde
voilà un tiers de la population vie un
territoire tout à fait on va donc s'il
n'y a pas d'autres intervention
oui donc je voulais rebondir sur le
centre de gestion des le CDG le centre
de gestion pour les sénateurs de mairie
moi je suis donnée donc en juin 2020
début septembre 2020 ma secrétaire part
en congé maladie j'appelle le CDG 90 ans
vous avez un service d'intérim
vous avez pas de chance elle est en
vacances rappeler dans 10 jours on verra
mais en attendant regardez autour de
vous voilà la réponse qu'on m'a faite
donc je regarde autour de moi je trouve
quelqu'un je rappelle quand même que je
suis pas maire depuis XX années donc
j'ai jamais embauché quelqu'un donc je
l'embauche comme ça et en effet on a
rempli le contrat de travail qu'en fin
de journée de travail et pas en début ou
le lendemain et donc elle s'est déjà me
rappelle deux jours après pour me
disputer pour me dire mais enfin Madame
vous ai pas fait les choses dans l'ordre
donc ce serait peut-être bien que
au moins que dans ces services là ils
puissent dire mais attendez quand j'ai
un maire au téléphone mais je lui donne
la procédure enfin je sais pas c'est
évident
voilà ça c'était mon témoignage merci
dernier dernier
juste pour signaler quand même tout à
l'heure sur la notion de compétences
parce que je me suis ressortir un
discours je le recentre c'était de dire
que quand on est une femme on nous en
demande toujours plus et que logiquement
dans nos devrait avoir l'autorité de
statut comme les autres et nous nous
demande toujours cette autorité de
compétence sur un dossier c'est ça
passerait différemment si on était un
homme et après quand je parlais de tous
les collègues hommes et femmes confondus
sur les responsabilités c'est parce que
quand je vois au niveau vous avez raison
des ruraux les responsabilités civiles
et pénales quand vous les regardez d'un
maire si vous avez pas un secrétaire de
mairie qui vous épaule pour les
signatures ça fait peur aux confrères de
s'engager ça leur fait peur parce que
les règles changent régulièrement les
lois s'appliquer rapidement et c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
responsabilités que nous important elle
elles ont de fortes conséquences quand
elles sont mal appliquées par nos
fonctionnaires territoriaux donc vous
avez raison c'est terrible pour un maire
notamment dans le paysage des ruraux de
pas être bien épaulé et juste je finis
une dernière chose c'est que sachez
quand même une chose c'est que c'est une
évolution au niveau j'allais dire
agricole et qu'on voit de plus en plus
de femmes dans ce genre de métier c'est
parce qu'il y a aussi une modernisation
des structures agricoles qui aujourd'hui
fait qu'il y a la modernisation et
l'automatisation qui a emmené que ces
femmes deviennent à la tête de ces sites
agricoles et qu'on est plus dans une
notion aussi que de force physique mais
bel et bien ce qui a été dit aussi
statistiquement les femmes bien souvent
en plus de diplômes et on le voit
notamment dans tout ce qui est ruraux
agroalimentaire et autres elles arrivent
à des statues d'ingénieurs et
statistiquement dans les écoles c'est
les femmes qui sont le plus diplômés
c'est lui aussi à cette modernité là
dans le réseau agricole voilà je tenais
à vous le dire merci oui aujourd'hui
nous avons débattu à la fois de la place
des femmes mais aussi en ruralité un
territoire bien spécifique et toutes les
problématiques moi je vous remercie et
je trouve que les échanges ont été très
riches intéressants et confondent tout
ça ça nous donne la pêche et ça nous
donne l'espoir pour le futur je crois
que c'est ça qui est le plus important
et bien écoutez à moi le mot de la fin
je ne peux pas finalement clôturer cette
matinée d'échange qui fait écho à la
journée du 8 mars sans vous remercier
chacun et chacune d'entre vous pour vos
participations évidemment penser à ceux
qui n'ont pas pu venir à cause de des
suppressions de train je voudrais tout
particulièrement remercier le président
Gérard Larcher comme je l'ai fait tout à
l'heure dans mon propos liminaire pour
son engagement à nos côtés et on sait
qu'on a une écoute et je vais citer un
exemple puisqu'il est parti nous avons
fait un gros travail au sein de la
délégation sur l'industrie de la
pornographie et grâce à à son engagement
et bien ce rapport qui était co-écrit
par plusieurs rapporteurs d'issus de
groupe différents et bien il a pu être
inscrit très rapidement à l'issue de nos
travaux grâce au président Larcher qui
n'a pas finalement demandé à ce qu'il
inscrit sur un espace réservé d'un
groupe et qu'il l'a pris sur un espace
réservé du Sénat et ça démontre
l'accompagnement et l'écoute que nous
avons au sein de la plus haute instance
c'est-à-dire de cette de cette assemblée
c'est-à-dire notre président Girard
Larcher particulièrement
intéressé à la ruralité c'est vrai que
nous avons la chance d'avoir un
président qui s'investit qui représente
les territoires et qui est au quotidien
aux côtés des territoires puisqu'il est
très très souvent sur le terrain dans
son département mais pas seulement donc
un remerciement particulier pour lui qui
nous a fait le plaisir d'être là hier
mais d'être là aussi ce matin malgré la
séance de nuit remercier forcément la
présidente Christian Lambert qui avec
qui nous avons l'habitude de travailler
dès qu'elle a été élue à la présidence
de la FNSEA nous l'avions reçu en
audition et
avait été un échange extrêmement
intéressant parce que on l'a vu ce matin
la parole elle est libre elle est
intéressante c'est un espace finalement
un espace de parole pour s'écouter se
comprendre et voir que finalement
peut-être et ben chacune ou chacun a des
difficultés qui sont souvent un petit
peu
identiques aux autres et qu'il y a des
des bonnes solutions des bonnes
pratiques qui peuvent être mises en
oeuvre collectivement remercier mes deux
cours rapporteurs et les cours
rapporteurs qui étaient qui n'étaient
pas forcément là mais qui avait
travaillé sur ce sujet à la fois
Jean-Michel Arnaud et Marie-Pierre
Monnier je dois vous dire que je suis
très heureuse de les avoir eu à mes
côtés ce matin puisqu'ils sont très
engagés ils avaient travaillé aussi dans
leur département sur ce sujet parce que
c'est bien de faire du travail au Sénat
c'est bien d'auditionner mais c'est
aussi bien de faire vivre nos travaux
dans nos départements donc ils ont
alimenté notre travail de manière
efficace sur le terrain et au Sénat donc
merci à tous les deux je voudrais vous
remercier toutes mesdames les maires
mesdames les conseillères
départementales et régionales pour avoir
participé activement à cette matinée
parce que c'est vrai que s'il y a pas
d'échange c'est pas intéressant on a eu
des échanges nourris sur les deux tables
rondes finalement que vous vous animiez
et comme je vais reprendre tout à
l'heure l'expression de Christiane
Lambert elle a dit c'était important de
s'engager sans renoncer et bien je dois
vous dire que moi-même je me suis
engagée à la fois dans c'est valable
pour tout en réalité à la fois dans ma
carrière professionnelle et dans ma dans
ma dans mon mandat politique sans
renoncer sans renoncer je crois que
quand elle l'a dit elle a tout de suite
fait écho à l'accompagnement c'est à
dire que pour ne pas avoir à renoncer il
faut être il faut avoir un environnement
favorable à l'engagement c'est-à-dire il
faut être soutenu quel que soit les
modes de soutien je parle pas forcément
d'un conjoint je parle aussi de d'amis
de famille il faut qu'on soit porté pour
que cet engagement ne soit pas un
renoncement et j'ai trouvé que ce
qu'elle disait était très intéressant
parce qu'il faut réussir on n'est pas
des bêtes de travail on a besoin d'un
temps personnel on a besoin d'un temps
professionnel d'un temps d'engagement et
il faut réussir à faire concilier tout
ça alors nous en tant que législateur
nous avons des responsabilités aussi
pour donner les moyens il est question
tout à l'heure des remplacements
forcément dans la pour les agricultrices
il est question de faire évoluer les
modes de garde d'adapter les modes de
garde et la mobilité au centre des
problématiques de des ruralité je
voudrais aussi terminer cette matinée
puisqu'on ça fait écho à une journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
nous avons la liberté de nous engager
nous en France nous avons la liberté
d'accéder à l'éducation nous avons la
liberté de travailler nous avons la
liberté aussi sur des droits sexuels et
reproductifs et bien moi je souhaite que
ces libertés que nous les défendions
tout ensemble et tous ensemble parce que
elle progresse que si nous avons des
hommes chers Jean-Michel j'ai réussi qui
est là aussi il y avait Bruno Belin tout
à l'heure nous progressons que si nous
avons des hommes et des femmes engagés
donc évidemment ces libertés c'est pas
elles sont pas acquises on doit les
protéger ses libertés on doit aussi les
protéger et se battre pour que dans des
territoires pas si éloignés de nous et
bien je pense à l'Iran je pensais à
l'Afghanistan je pense à l'Ukraine ou
toutes ces femmes sont privées de ces
libertés donc battons-nous pour faire
progresser l'égalité
dans l'engagement politique les qualités
salariales l'égalité tout court et
engageons-nous aussi pour faire
progresser l'égalité la lutte contre les
violences dans en France dans les
territoires ultramarins évidemment chère
Micheline mais dans dans le monde aussi
parce qu'il est question des jeunes
femmes et des jeunes filles est-ce qu'on
gagne ici on le gagne aussi pour elle je
vous remercie vraiment sincèrement
[Applaudissements]